vladimir putin
the arch enemy of these united states
he's an assassin and a murderer he kills
journalists and now he's comparing the
us and what they're doing to trump
supporters to what the u.s is claiming
about him
saying basically what he's doing to
alexia navalny the opposition leader is
the same thing
the u.s is doing to trump supporters and
he even asked the press
did you assassinate ashley babbitt and
wow putin he's uh he's uh he's roast in
the united states and uh joe biden ain't
got nothing
joe biden at the g7 ain't got nothing
there's like a video of him wandering
around confused looking around
and then jill runs up and grabs him and
everyone busts out
laughing at our president it's
absolutely insane
in one speech he accidentally says libya
instead of syria could you imagine
if the president was having a meeting
with like say saudi arabia and they were
like
we need you know we've got this conflict
in syria we need weapons and
then biden's like we'll give you weapons
for libya and they're like
sure i guess and he accidentally ends up
refocusing foreign policy and libya
because he just said the wrong word
man and so there's another story where
apparently he was asked about if putin
is a killer and he just goes
freezes up for like 20 something seconds
and
uh shameful day america this is the guy
that we elected because the other guy
was
nasty or naughty or orange i guess i'm
reminded of that tweet i think it was
alyssa milano where she's like he's
literally orange
it's part of his strategy and i'm like
she was actually complaining the man was
orange
that's it great well this is what we get
at the g7 so we're going to be talking
about this we've also got this reporter
broke the news on the clinton loretta
lynch scandal who apparently
took his own life according to certain
reports so we'll definitely get into
that
plus some other news about uh a
journalist appearing on tv
announcing live that she has been
recording footage for project veritas
and then like the show just carries on
like normal so it'll be fun
joining us today is clint russell from
liberty lockdown podcast you want to
just briefly introduce yourself yes
i am clint from libby lockdown um i am
a former private money mortgage broker
entrepreneur turned
liberty ranter and uh i started during
the lockdown hence the name of the show
liberty lockdown and i uh
kind of in the dave smith camp i'm kind
of one of his proteges
um dude oh he's amazing he's a future
president
i'll vote for him yeah i saw i saw his
thing on gut fell i think was on
goodfell and i was like i'll vote for
this guy
he's all right he's good we've had him
here uh you know before so but uh
we'll also talk about like black rock
buying up houses and you know a lot
about that too
i do yes because of my my experience in
the private money lending world
i understand the real estate market
really well i'm also currently building
six houses so i can uh
i can help advise as to maybe why you
got declined for that loan and
what it all means that's a lot of houses
all right and ladies and gentlemen you
already know but uh
this guy is living in a parking lot
again tim i gotta correct you
biden didn't just confuse syria with
libya once he confused it
three times in 90 seconds welcome back
beautiful amazing human beings i heard
your cries of no luke
we puke and i am here for you seriously
anything i did i was shooting machine
guns posted it
in florida on my instagram down below
hashtag
no luke we puke and hey what do you know
anything i did no matter what it was it
was like
why aren't you here at the beanie
compound i am here i barely made it
it was a crazy ride but it was an
incredible journey
all throughout the united states mexico
bitcoin conference key west
i i got so many stories i met so many
amazing wonderful human beings
that we're fans of this show we're fans
of we are change we're fans of
independent media
we're critical thinking individuals and
i have so many experiences i have to
share but uh enough about me
thank you so much for having me back i'm
excited you're back man
you said were at the bitcoin conference
in florida it was wild like 10 000
some people 12 000 people all in a huge
arena
it was just spectacular ron paul opened
up the conference
wow there was messages from ross
ulbricht every single day ross albert
got put in solitary confinement because
of his messages
to the bitcoin conference uh yeah so uh
freeross.org there's a lot of
information about that
it was just overwhelming seeing so many
freedom-oriented people at this bitcoin
space the bitcoin space usually is
dominated with a whole bunch of like
usually money people but this time
around it was all about freedom
personal responsibility and liberty and
it was incredible to see sorry i'm going
off
i've got so much to say i got so many
stories look at these shirts so many
things make america florida
so many things we talked about on this
show when we were on here fauci bill
gates the economy
lockdowns medications jabs everything we
talked about
all of it has been coming true when the
mainstream media was telling us
no no no the opposite's true we were
lying this was not true this is all
conspiracy theories
everything we were discussing on this
show has come true
uh so uh we have to acknowledge all of
that
uh especially bill gates dr fauci
finally getting the reckoning
and and and people understanding the
true corruptness that truly lies within
this larger power establishment okay i
got more torrent sorry go ahead okay
we also got another important member
here as well oh yeah well there's ian
we're gonna give him his due i'm also in
the corner pressing buttons for these
wild guys wish me luck tonight it's
going to be a heck of a ride
there's tim before we get started my
friends you must go to timcast.com and
become a member why
well around 11 or so we put up the bonus
segment
sometimes a full-on episode and i think
we're gonna have a full episode because
we're gonna get really offensive and
these are these are the shows that
youtube doesn't allow us to have on
youtube
we have on the website and i think i can
also now announce that the newsroom
officially launches
i think tomorrow it might not because of
formatting issues
but uh i'm gonna the person that we're
bringing on to start
running the newsroom you guys are huge
fans of and uh like seriously people are
huge fans of and uh
so i'm not gonna say anything just yet
until she comes and starts uh
producing and we and we're we're for
sure that it officially launched
and then i think the the new overhaul is
going to be happening for the website in
the next like
two and a half or three weeks yeah these
things get pushed back a little bit
because we got to do some some testing
to make sure that when we launch it
doesn't disrupt anybody's viewing
experience and
the videos get liked or whatever but
we're gonna start having articles i
believe
starting tomorrow and lots of them uh
assuming the current version can handle
it i think it can
and then you're gonna see the byline of
the person writing and then we're
already hiring a couple more people
and putting this list together i think
we have like five people within the next
like week or two
maybe three weeks it's gonna be legit
and it's because you guys as members
have helped support the show that we
have the ability to do this
and we're gonna start fact checking the
fact checkers and we're going to start
writing these articles we're going to
start pumping out the news and it's
going to be great
um so also just just time to become a
member because we got that extra segment
coming up
let's jump into this news man vladimir
putin
from independent putin tells biden
don't be mad at the mirror if you are
ugly
compare he compares capital riders to
his own descent this is amazing
vladimir putin sought to compare
crackdowns on his political enemies
and the arrest of anti-government
protesters in his country to the events
of january 6 in an interview
published by nbc news speaking with
journalists in moscow mr putin claimed
that the u.s and other countries had no
evidence for allegations of election
interference
ransomware attacks and other malicious
activities for which the west has blamed
russia
or russian-based actors in recent years
he also pointed to the arrests of
hundreds of suspected participants
in u.s capital in the u.s capitol right
on january 6 as evidence
that the biden administration or us was
targeting americans based on their
political opinions
you guys ready for this one quote did
you order the assassination of the woman
who walked into the congress and who was
shot and killed by a policeman
mr putin said referring to ashley
babbitt a californian who died during
the riot
after being shot by a member of the u.s
capitol police who was cleared of
wrongdoing in her death
do you know that 450 individuals were
arrested after entering the congress
and they didn't go there to steal a
laptop they came with political demands
said mr putin
the u.s he reasoned was guilty of the
same intolerance for political dissent
as his government has been accused of
harboring putin's government in recent
months has cracked down on an
organization run by alexei navalny
a top critic of the russian president
and requested that a court order
uh that a court order to be classified a
court order it to be classified as an
extremist organization his organization
mr navalny remains in prison after
surviving an assassination attempt via
novacic a soviet-era nerve agent the u.s
uk and numerous other western nations
have blamed russia for the attack
which mr putin had has denied we don't
have this kind of habit
of assassinating anybody mr putin said
in the interview with nbc
and this is what you really got you got
to understand the other day
we have uh our friend andreas you may
seem in the cas castle vlogs
he was playing video footage just in the
basement of a normal day walking through
moscow
and it's really interesting when you see
this it's just a video of someone
wearing a gopro and they're walking down
the street in moscow and you can see the
shops and the cell phone stores and boy
does it look the exact same as it does
like walking in a street in new york
whatever i mean i get i get it the
architecture is a little bit different
then you realize you know a lot of
people don't realize this when you're in
russia
the news you hear they don't say putin
is the demon devil
they say they're going to be hearing
very very similar things to what we hear
about you know in the united states
they're going to be hearing things about
the u.s very similar to what
we hear about russia so it's interesting
we are
seeing a lot of people who look there's
a lot of people on january 6 we always
say it
did stupid things and they're gonna get
arrested and charged for it but what
about the insurrection
over the past year that's still going on
to this day that's not been dealt with
in the democrats who support it
putin saying what uh what a lot of
people i think in america don't want to
hear
and what a lot of people haven't
acknowledged yet which is pretty big
is that what's happening to some of the
people that attended the january 6th
event is absolutely atrocious
there's huge violations of human human
rights there's people being put in
solitary confinement
there's allegations of torture there's
people who can't get lawyers there's
lawyers who are afraid to represent
people
and then putin on the national stage to
the u.s mainstream media
brought this up and and i think he makes
a very fair equivalent
i mean the united states points fingers
at countries that violating human rights
well
let's really look at at all human rights
objectively
and let's let's look at it from a way
where we could actually impact it and
make a difference
putin also went on and called biden a
career politician
those are also very big statements from
uh from vladimir putin
from the same person who also described
the american political system
as being previously ruled by men in
black suits this is a putin
characterization
of the american political system and i
think there's some merit to that
especially when you look into black rock
the federal reserve
and all these other multinational
billionaire corporations that really
truly have
an invested interest in getting their
policies approved meanwhile
popular policies never do get passed so
this is going to be interesting because
putin and biden will be meeting
face-to-face
in two days and what's going to happen
i mean this is going to be huge vladimir
putin previously
went up to joe biden on the world stage
and said you know what you just called
me a killer
let's have a one-on-one international
debate no rules
no pre-scripted questions me and you
just talking to the entire world
what did biden respond true to not shy
but pressure come on man
i think those are fairly accurate he
didn't he didn't respond just like he
didn't respond to today's question when
he was asked about
calling putin a killer he kind of walked
it back a little bit and it was kind of
stuck for
for 25 minutes again minutes seconds 25
seconds
apologies it's like he was sitting there
for a long time yeah yeah it almost felt
like 25 minutes personally
with just how long the gap was but but
there this is going to be very
interesting to see how this is going to
be unfolding in the next two days
because tensions between these
these two countries the united states
and russia couldn't be any higher and
the stakes couldn't be any higher as
well
to be fair like hasn't vladimir putin
bounced back and forth between like
president
and prime minister or whatever doing
that trick to remain in power yes
he has yeah so you know there's room for
criticism just like he said hey
you got alexey nevali we got ashley
babbitt uh
and and there's some you know let's be
honest here there there's something to
intellectually
uh you know entertain here yeah i think
the issue is that
in my lifetime the an american president
hasn't had the moral high ground
to talk [ __ ] to putin i mean that that's
my that's my perspective is that
ultimately is he a bad guy sure has
anyone
ruled our country that has been a good
guy in my lifetime
no quite the opposite no so uh it's
weird because i feel
i still i still hold on to these tinges
of patriotism where i'm like
no no no i have to i have to stand with
my
nation but the truth is when i hear
putin talk about our politicians in
particular
i find a lot to agree with we should
criticize all of them if someone
violates human rights no matter who they
are
what they are human rights should always
matter above politics and sadly we don't
have that in our mainstream system that
is just
focused on doing the bidding of the
military-industrial complex because when
a country that has an
alliance with the united states that has
geopolitical strategy to be gained by
the state department we don't see any
criticisms of human rights violations
then
that doesn't happen but when there's a
goal and there's an aim there's some oil
there's some natural resources there's
there's some petrol dollar politics that
could be played here oh we're going to
be talking about it non-stop
i think also to be fair back either way
i can point out you know putin has
retained power for a long time
but what's the difference between the
devil you know and the devil you don't
when we have a political system which it
is the exact same people pushing all the
buttons
they just put a different front person
and it's like oh here's the current
iteration of the neoconservative or
neo-liberal establishment
they're it's the same party they all
agree on the same thing in fact the only
difference we've seen in the past
in my lifetime was donald trump and then
the neoconservatives joined the neolibs
and formed the
the like this outright uniparty which we
just jokingly
referred to at the unit party before
ultimately just said okay we're all on
the same side we don't like trump and
we're gonna do everything in the power
to stop him
i don't i don't see a big difference to
be completely honest i don't i don't see
a huge difference either and
uh hans herman hopper actually argued
that that monarchy was superior to
democracy for
exactly what you just described that you
have first off you have consistency but
also
you have a guy who is committed to the
long-term
success of his nation because he
realizes he's going to be there for a
while
and with putin you know he's like i'm
going to be there for 20 years i'm going
to take this seriously just
for the record not advocating for
monarchy i'm just saying that
there has been an argument made yeah but
but what you said in the beginning of
this broadcast with people walking in
moscow looking exactly at the people who
walk in new york city
uh you know the people are the losers
here the real winners are the
military-industrial complex whenever we
see these two heads of states clash
and we saw a very serious clash point
just a few weeks ago there was massive
troops building up on the ukraine
russian border
there was massive u.s nato forces being
sent in there was war games tensions
were really high
who won who benefits off of that larger
geopolitical conundrum that is ukraine
right now that is a proxy war that is
happening right now
that people are dying in right now as
we're speaking who's winning
not the people the shareholders the
missiles
lockheed martin
yeah because the the people like if our
government screws up and then our
country suffers from conflict and debt
those those shareholders those those uh
you know executives
they can cash out that currency to any
other currency they want and jump ship
yeah that's what they're doing it's it's
they're they're they're profiting off
our backs they're extracting value from
our system
and they're playing with countries that
are proxies whether it's yemen whether
it's syria whether it's ukraine and
they're playing with real life
and a lot of people die from this
ukraine joe biden just also announced
that ukraine quotes
quote must clean up their corruption
before joining nato
that's another backstep to again a very
hardline policy just said that he just
said it's the same thing they've been
saying going back five six years
and when you look at donald trump donald
trump was the first president to give
lethal aid to ukraine which absolutely
uh angered russia and also escalated the
situation
now we're seeing a bigger escalation on
top of all of that what joe biden
calling him
a killer he's now trying to walk back
those statements biden's also blaming
him for the
hacking ransom attacks that have been
happening here and another big aspect of
this story that people are forgetting
the the ransom hacking attacks are
linked
many times to nsa spying toolkits
that were paid for by american tax
dollars and were let loose
on the internet the tools used for these
ransom attacks were created by the nsa
and now the mainstream media along with
joe biden are saying it's russia
when even intelligence agencies in the
united states are saying no no it's not
russia there's no way to find out
because it's online this is one of the
craziest things the daily mail kept
saying all these hacks were russian
linked russian linked
and i'm looking at these articles and
i'm like there's no evidence for that
and then joe biden himself comes out and
says
it's not russian linked and then he said
it is russian he said it might no no
it might be people in russia exactly but
not the russian government not the
country itself just individuals yes
and and now he's been asked about this
and putin responded and he's saying
where's the evidence i want to see the
evidence are you going to hold me
responsible for black lives matter as
well
those are literally putin's statements
today
the democrats have been accusing russia
of propping up these these facebook
pages and putting money into black lives
matter
as well as right-wing groups for years
now so yes they are blaming him
but i'll tell you something guys i have
i have a sad truth to inform you of uh
i think joe biden is a russian agent
that's right at the very least an asset
of the russian government or a useful
idiot for the russians
sound familiar so we got the story from
becker news
stunned silence overseas after joe
biden's bizarre reaction to killer putin
question
joe biden is proving to be the laughing
stock of the nato summit although the
embarrassing development is no laughing
matter
cnn's chief national affairs
correspondent jeff zeleny asked biden a
question
about vladimir putin in brussels uh
biden's response was odd to say the
least quote
in a weekend interview vladimir putin
laughed at the suggestion that you
called him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he's
a killer quote
and i will continue to continue the
trend of asking a second question he
continued
do you believe that if he does agree to
cooperate then what kind of challenge do
you find yourself in
how would you ever trust him if ronald
reagan said trust but verify
what do you say to vladimir putin zeleny
asked
this was biden's rambling response
answer the first question i'm laughing
too he said in awkward science they
actually i
well look he has made clear that uh uh
the answer is i believe that he has in
the past
essentially acknowledged that he was uh
there's certain things that he would or
did do but look
when i was asked a question on the air i
answered honestly but it's not much of a
i don't think it matters a lot in terms
of okay you get the point oh my god
so so i'm not i'm not being serious when
i say he's a russian agent yeah i'm just
making fun of the democrats
but what about uh what what about joe
biden shuts down keystone pipeline and
then he approves
the the ukraine pipeline he's giving
russia
pipeline access while shutting down
american pipelines that especially at a
time
whitmer in michigan wanted to shut down
another oil pipeline the colonial
pipeline gets shut down
what do these people work for it's
almost like it's amazing because
i don't know if you guys have probably
heard the democrats project that's what
they do
they'll do something and then accuse
republicans of doing it all they do is
project
were they literally projecting the
russian asset thing were they literally
agents of russia
saying like well don't look at us it's
trump he works for russia meanwhile
they're the ones working for russia
i think it's highly probable i mean i
mean not literally no but i mean it's
it's genuinely possible i like i i think
that there's
if it's not russia it's china i don't
think that our politicians are owned by
us
anymore that's my personal opinion i
know it's it's wonky conspiracy theory
stuff but
um i don't see much behavior on their on
their part that
demonstrates affinity or allegiance to
this nation that's just my personal
opinion well i agree but i don't think
it's
like they're owned by somebody else's
necessarily some probably are i mean
sualwell was was hooking up with
uh with fung fung or whatever bang thing
it's fung fung okay
get your pronunciations right you bigot
okay anyway the point is
uh now i forgot what i was gonna say
because uh
what were we talking about oh yeah yeah
yeah politicians are being owned fang
fang i started thinking about like what
was he doing with that lady
yeah i don't know what he was really
still want to know i just want to see
the video i don't know well
dianne feinstein right she had that
driver who was a spy or whatever the
point is
it's not that they're necessarily owned
by other people it's that they're they
have no allegiance to us
their allegiance is to extract value
from the system walk away
pad their bank accounts these are here's
what you need to understand about
congress
these are mediocre people at best and
that's being generous
who found a way to get rich and stamp
their name in the history books
they've done nothing of real merit other
than convince people to vote for them
or to put money behind their name so
other people see them on tv
then they become famous by virtue of
winning an election many of them
disappear
some of them never become prominent
enough but their name is in the history
book
they get they get they get that that
salary for a little bit some of them get
rich off of it
look at aoc she's got an infinity pool
she got a tesla
man she's she's doing really well from a
bartender ain't it her boiler is not
doing so hot but you know
no i think her whale is doing really
well apparently she said something like
they did get the money from trump oh
they did
something like that i don't know i don't
i i i saw an article that said
that apparently puerto rico her family
did get the aid okay
and that's what she came out and spoke
out against aoc which was a huge
admission and and really should be
talked about more because
aoc was trying to of course exploit her
poor grandmother and and it backfired
so tremendously to the fact where she
had to deny donations to her
poor grandmother i mean if if you're at
a political
point in your life or you have to say no
no no no don't give my poor
downtrodden grandmother yeah don't give
my abuelita
some money i mean that's that's when you
know you're messing up but
we actually do have the story though uh
aoc's aunt says blame puerto rico not
trump for abuela misery right puerto
rico received hurricane relief funding
but it hasn't reached all the people who
need help
an aunt of new york congresswoman claims
according to a report so she's
she's exploiting her family i'm not here
to rehash like some stupid aoc thing but
it's a really good example of
she is the she is the epitome of i'm the
working class i was a bartender and the
conservatives hate me for being a
bartender because they're elitists and
i'm here fighting for you
and parking my tesla illegally when i go
shop for some organic produce in my
luxury
apartment in dc within the infinity pool
and look at my poor abuelita she needs
your help and then it turns out
it's actually not trump's fault at all
because they did get there
that is exploiting and extracting value
from the system but hey hey
i'm not here to single out aoc i can
point the finger at each and every one
of these republicans
who do literally nothing but sit on
their hands
and there was a lot of corruption in
puerto rico especially after
a lot of money was sent from mainline
united states to
help with the hurricane relief there and
a lot of
a lot of the puerto rican government
officials some of them kept that money
for themselves a lot of them even locked
up
huge important resources in warehouses
for themselves so there was a huge
corruption that was ultimately
pointed directly at donald trump and the
mainstream media said look donald
trump's responsible for puerto rico
meanwhile you know a lot of puerto rican
politicians got caught with stealing a
lot of the aid
and they may or like steal something i
forgot the exact stories but i remember
seeing warehouses of of water bottles
that were absolutely huge and then
it never made it to to people who'd
never had running water
um and that wasn't donald trump who did
that and remember when trump was was
throwing like paper towels to people
like it was a sporting event yes and
they're like what a scumbag and i'm like
he's so cavalier
yeah i literally just didn't understand
why that who cared yeah and i'm not even
i'm not even a donald trump fan i never
was a fan of his i always criticized him
but but still when the mainstream media
is so ridiculously just trying to blame
everything on him whether it's puerto
rico whether it's the hurricane whether
it's the ebola
uh abuela or whatever grandmother or or
you know whatever the mainstream media
is against i have to look into and
investigate because
you usually see something that is not
what the mainstream media says it is and
they were foaming at the mouth going
crazy for russia
for a very long time and they were wrong
when it came to the russian collusion
story that started it all when donald
trump came in and russia was
was used as the boogeyman as the main
chief enemy of the united states and all
the information that came out
eventually proved that it was all wrong
it was all basically so
why do why do believe any believe
anything they say about anything i don't
i i i because the weather man's right
sometimes so it gives credibility to the
to the stupid news so but no i mean like
we we still
i got fox news and yahoo and the
independent pulled up and we take we
take these articles at their word
even though we know a good portion of
the time it's bonked
to be fair i actually go through these
articles for the most part and try and
like
you know i pulled up becker news for
instance and this is this is a
it's not newsguard certified or anything
but there's literally a tweet video of
of
joe biden doing this so that's something
i can actually verify
to a certain degree maybe the video was
edited i have no idea
but most of these these news outlets you
know they come out they talk about china
and one of the big fears i have
especially we were talking to talking to
cassandra fairbanks about war
what if they're just lying again they
lied about about iraq and the middle
east and wmds
so what if they're just lying again i
think i think it's a healthy development
honestly that
so many people have woken up to this
reality that there is nothing
trustworthy
out there i mean you tune into tim pool
to find out the truth more often than
you do
cnn and that's the truth i mean most
most people will rely on
our smaller outlets to try and get some
semblance of
object objectivity to be fair though cnn
gets hundreds of millions of views
they're propped up by youtube
youtube will put them on the front page
and we get downrank d ranked we get
hidden we get shadow banned
people say oh i don't get notifications
for your show anymore yeah that's right
so you know what man you guys if you're
listening you go to tmps.com become a
member
you share this show right now you take
the url right now you put it on facebook
twitter or whatever
because there's there's no way for us to
beat a rigged game unless everybody
stands up
and and does something look i'm not
saying this is the best show in the
world and i'm always right but if you at
least think we deserve more ratings than
cnn
share the show yep i'll uh i'll pop on
youtube and i'll see a video
frequently too and it'll say like the
fouchy interview like it's the big one
it'll be some random youtuber i've never
heard of 500 000 views
wow like it is just shoved to the to the
front that's what they want you
if you if you're one of these these are
the grifters of youtube not all of them
some of them are just like you know
dopey pop culture youtubers
but when they get their news from from
fake media
lying press all that stuff just fake
news
they believe it and then youtube says
hey we'll put you on the front page if
you interview fouchy and they go cool
and they don't know
anything it's really remarkable to me
how angry so many people are on twitter
when they clearly have no idea what
they're talking about and of course
there's the left grifters who will play
semantic games
then there are these run-of-the-mill
like regular lefties who just
never read a news article one day they
stumble across a piece of news where
it's like
something weird happens like that's
strange what's happening and then they
believe all the lies they believe all
the lies
then when people try and introduce into
a show like this they'll say i don't
know man that sounds like fake news the
media told me
brian stelter he was like don't watch
that youtube
he said not to so i'm not gonna don't
read the wikileaks it's illegal
as cnn was telling us before a few years
ago when the
wikileaks hillary clinton emails were
coming out actually showing us a totally
different perspective
of the reality of who hillary clinton
really was to who she was presented as
in the mainstream media
you look at how bill gates is presented
dr fauci is presented it's like they're
lord and saviors it's like they're
the scientists when bill gates is not a
medical doctor
or a scientist which which needs to be
reiterated and and
you know truly one of the most important
things that
i believe we should do and i've been
trying to do
on my own independent you know youtube
channel is to try to make people
critically think
is to try to make people understand that
you shouldn't believe anyone
unless you do your own research unless
you do your own homework and
you get to see different perspectives
and then make up your own mind on them
you're right but a lot of people just
want to be in the tribe they just
look matt look when youtube says hey
we're gonna put you on
you want a million subscribers you want
to be a big famous youtuber with the
gold medal
hey we'll do that for you just agree
with dr fauci no matter what he says and
interview him
then the emails come out now what we get
after the emails come out which show
yeah he was lying for sure
questioning whether or not his own uh
the nih funding was contributing to this
that it was actually it was actually
suspected that may have been the case
and then publicly said no it's not true
it's a lie
it's not it's not real no it's it's the
lab leak isn't true and
his own scientists that he was
consulting with believed it was possible
yeah i'm not saying
it was like fauci behind the scenes
laughing and mocking people telling me
how smart he was and how he was
manipulating everybody
but behind the scenes he very much was
holding his private positions
and then publicly giving different
positions yeah and if if
if not for rand paul we probably don't
even know about this i mean that we
would have known about the emails but we
wouldn't have had him on the record
just prior to that release where he
denies it all i thought it was profound
and
and you know this is these these are the
types of things that
all of us were privy to because we do
our own research but but as you were
saying people need to be more critical
and and i wish they were but the truth
is you can only lead people to water
most don't want to drink
and you know i just think you have to
you have to find your own tribe
i just got a one one quick caveat i was
just very very critical of congress
rand paul gets a pass thank you he's not
perfect but i always he's pretty good
he's better than most
yeah him and messi so you guys are
telling me that cnn and buzzfeed when
they said that the fouchy emails only
showed how hard you work wasn't true
that was amazing so they leak all these
emails or they they get they foil them
freedom of information and then
buzzfeeds like leaked emails show
how how fauci was fighting hard to keep
america stable
just like us oh jeez frank frank honesty
is that what it said
yeah a refreshing source of friends and
then
when fauci comes out later he's like if
they're criticizing me
they're criticizing science i am sorry
he didn't really say i am science
i am undebunkable oh then he flipped the
table over yeah he didn't really do that
they're gonna call me fake news they're
gonna be like false did [ __ ] you
tim poole light on the show snopes he
did say the first part though if you
criticize me you're criticizing science
so so hold on this one's great this
one's great you guys are gonna love this
what do you think
uh uh rachel maddow had to say about
vladimir putin's comments
on january 6 ashley webb so let me just
do a quick context here
for those that missed the first part of
this of the show vladimir putin came out
and said you guys basically you
criticized me over alexi navalny and the
opposition protests
but look what you're doing the trump
supporters and the january six riot like
look what you're doing people
and then he actually asked did you order
the assassination of ashley
of the woman who was shot by that police
officer he comes out really critical
now what do you think rachel maddow of
msnbc
said that that putin was doing she
combusted
she exploded yes she burst in no way
dude
she reached her purest form this is
exactly what she lives for vladimir
putin coming out
and defending trump supporters her eyes
started glowing
and she started emitting a powerful aura
she levitated from her chair
msnbc putin's russia adopts
republican talking points on january
6 riot on january 6 far-right
republicans
have a political ally once again in
vladimir putin
who's only too pleased to amplify their
talking points
russia's back i was worried for a minute
i was sad i missed i missed talking
about you know all the russian nonsense
uh thank you rachel maddow you know i
bet she cried
when putin came out and said this said
this because when the mueller report
came out
saying that you know donald trump did
not collude there was no evidence she
was nearly crying
and there's that really funny video with
women's filming and she's like shaking
with laughter like she's crying
she's crying and rachel that i was like
there's nothing
here she like she didn't really start
crying
but you know she was like holding back
you would think these people would have
some kind of
like wake up to reality you would think
these people after
crying on national television after
lying to the american people for four
years telling us russian collusion trump
is russia russia's involved in our
politics russia
still you know changed the elections you
would think after that realization after
that huge pie
in her face still preferably there in my
opinion
just an absolute disgrace for four years
you would think
they would just stop it but they double
down it's intentional that's why yeah
obviously i mean i think some kid with a
vpn might have flipped it on and
and worked out of a russian ip i mean
there's no way
there's no that conversation's never
even entered rach i've never heard
rachel maddow or anybody like talk
like postulate is it possible that some
for corporation is working with a
russian ip
it could be anybody i've never heard
them mention a vpn as a possible
answer to why we think it's from russia
and and we also have
the the world economic forum talked
about
we we want to get away from capitalism
we want to get away from meat
we want to uh what was the other one you
own nothing oh get away from oil
and then we had a lockdown that shut
down the economy for a year
and then we had what else we had the
pipeline
that got hacked the meat the meat hack
and then the meat hack those are all
those are
all beneficial for the uh very
interestingly the world economic forum
is doing cyber polygon
their digital online war games they're
going to be doing it in a few days from
now they did it last year
they're going to do it again this year
and they're literally practicing
and drilling big severe war games that
damage the infrastructure of countries
so they've been
they've been they've been like exactly
drilling this last year they're doing it
again this year with a whole bunch of
corporations a whole bunch of
governments involved
in this larger cyber polygon
uh world economic forum project that
they're pushing to the to the lexicon
again world economic forum huge entity
we got it right here i just want to
issue one clarification too the rachel
maddow comments were about
last week putin said something very
similar that the people who stormed the
capital were
there with political demands basically
the same thing he said recently but not
the ashley babbitt part
but yes we also have the worldeconomic
forum.org
newsguard certified so you know it's
legit cyber polygon and they say
is a unique cyber security event that
combines the world's largest technical
training exercise for corporate teams
and an online conference featuring
senior officials from international
organizations and leading corporations
they're saying it's an online conference
obviously it's a cyber security event so
there's going to be an aspect of
you know obviously cyber security wasn't
there something that uh uh
what was it cloud schwab said about a
digital kind of pandemic where we're
getting the cyber attacks and the damage
that it can wreak
he said that too yeah he won't he warned
about it i i don't i don't remember the
details but
he was bringing it up in the same uh you
know lane as the pandemic so
yeah a lot of people are bringing up
event 201. i'm not saying
you know correlation is causation and
even with this hacking stuff
it could be russia it could be china it
could be israel israel also
hacked uh american systems and spied on
american politicians and spied on
american infrastructure stole
american secrets sold it to china not a
lot of people know this the online
digital paper ship
yeah yeah the online digital cyber space
is
is a crazy world where even allies hack
other allies
now with these nsa spying tools
available for everyone
that were paid for by your tax dollars
these ransom attacks
there's a lot more of them that we don't
even know about because there's a lot
there's no news reports about them and
then i think they're happening a lot
more than we even
know because just like you know
there's you know sporting events where
they make sure that they don't
uh film people who run on on the stage
you know i think this is also a similar
thing that's unfolding right now and it
should be questioned especially with the
latest
fbi retrieval of these bitcoins because
that
story also doesn't add up because these
sophisticated hackers somehow
put their bitcoin that they got on a
wallet that they didn't have the private
keys on
that the fbi was just able to get a
subpoena from the server you stole
millions and you put it on a hot wallet
and you put a hot wallet where you don't
know the price that was weird that's
weird that's super weird and the story
doesn't add up
the story does not add up about these
cyber attacks and online
there could be false flags it could be
other countries it could be iran it
could be
kenya could be you know who who knows it
could be private
corporate interest i'ma say something
not to overly speculate but i just want
to point out there was
a colonial pipeline hack shut down large
pipeline in the country we had the jbs
meat hack
shut down i think a fifth of the beef
production in this country
we had a chemical plant just burst into
flames blow up in illinois
don't know that's related to anything
but we had another oil refinery in iran
blows up i remember when donald trump
was flying some planes to iran he was
going to wipe he was going to do an
airstrike i think on the coast
take out some of their surface-to-air
stuff or whatever and then all of a
sudden they were treated
and then trump said he asked he you know
he asked his advisors how many people
would die over this
and they said it was gonna be like a
hundred is that it's not worth taking
that many lives over what's happening
the interesting thing is you know what
happened in between
that airstrike from when the planes
launched when they turn around
i think it could be wrong so faction on
this one because been a while there was
a plant in philadelphia some kind of
like refinery that that went up in
flames
now i asked my cyber security friends if
they thought that maybe iran issued a
like
it's called a industrial control system
attack and i see i think it's called
ics uh attacked us and then trump
panicked they said no
no no that's probably not the case
probably not the case so okay okay all
right
i'll air on that on that side but i will
point out if there was
major cyber attacks happening do you
think they're going to come out and just
be like oh by the way you know iran just
blew up one of our facilities of course
they wouldn't why
they don't they want war when they want
war not when they don't want war
so they the the united states government
doesn't want to be forced into a war if
they came out and said
we've actually were attacked in this
regard the american people would be
living
they'll control the flow of information
and the moment they actually do want to
launch an assault
it'll be all over every single tv didn't
we start this with stuxnet with the
uh nuclear refinement and i don't think
started it
well i don't know i don't know who
started it
it's been happening for a very long time
and the online cyberspace
is is congested with wars upon wars
allies spying on allies allies attacking
allies it's such a complicated space so
just to
blame everything on russia is also kind
of a little bit worrying
especially with the latest troop
movements that happened uh
just a few weeks ago so so seeing the
mainstream media
fully point the picture at russia during
these events is is a little bit worrying
to be honest with you because as you
said if they want to prop
up a war they could easily prop up a war
and right now they're saying russia
russia russia
and that brings me back to the main
point rachel maddow coming out with a
smile on her face and a sparkle in her
eye
oh vladimir putin's defending trump
thank you
that's what she needed she needs to
justify she needs to prove to her
audience that it wasn't four years
wasted
and with the scariest thing to me the
people who believe it
the people who have been lied to over
and over again for
years still come crawling back for more
begging please lie to me i have
relatives that are that way it's
mind-blowing i
i don't understand how after five years
of getting promised
these smoking guns and getting nothing
getting no source material whatsoever
and we were talking about with the the
hacks and things that are happening even
if you get reporting on it you don't get
any sourced
information like they will say i mean
the source will be a high-ranking
pentagon official that doesn't i'm sorry
but that's not good enough for me
not in 2021 i'm gonna need a little bit
more than that there's nothing more
trustworthy than an anonymous source
from the military-industrial complex and
intelligence agencies yes i i wouldn't
believe it
uh but but again this is this is big i
mean
we're heading into a time that's that's
extremely perplexing extremely worrying
because on the online digital space you
could do anything
and the realm of possibility is far and
wide so
uh and it's and it's impossible to get
any real concrete evidence
i wouldn't be surprised if mutually
assured destruction existed in the cyber
realm now too like we have
obviously nukes ready to go if anybody
but like if you invade here we're
shutting down all your oil refineries
the chinese could do it to the united
states could do the chinese the russians
could do it to the indians the indians
could do the united states
so we're all like in this i don't that
weird mexican standoff term like has
nothing to do with mexico anymore it's
like we're all
ready to move and not no one wants to
take the first step because their
infrastructure is going to get torched
but with cyber security it's different
with uh with nukes
if like so mexican santa fe is
unfamiliar it's like there's three
people
and they're each pointing guns at each
other and no one wants to shoot first
because then they'll get shot
so whoever shoots first loses the first
guy who gets shot goes down then the guy
who shoots get shot by the other guy the
last guy standing so nobody wants to
move
when you get a bunch of countries with
nukes sure they could theoretically be
like okay
fire our nukes at all of the major
capitals maybe they don't have enough i
think russia might and the us might
china probably doesn't have enough nukes
but they've got it they've got a decent
amount india and pakistan i think have
nukes
so it's it's still a mexican standoff
the us is like if we fire our nukes at
russia
we'll get hit from other countries with
cybers with cyber attacks
we could have infected every industrial
control system across the planet
and with the press of a button shut it
all down so it's not necessarily
however i'd be willing to bet that their
nukes of other countries
they've got manual operation so in the
event the u.s says
shut down all of the industrial controls
for as many countries as possible
the nukes will start flying and we don't
have the ability to take them all out
there's a bunch of
there's been a bunch of uh efforts to be
able to stop nuclear weapons like it's
one one was called the strategic defense
initiative i think the sdi system
and that was trying to fire rockets and
blow up by icbms in midair
kind of like how the iron dome works in
israel and then we i think we have the
thaad in south korea but it's not enough
one nuke gets through and you you take
out a city especially if it explodes in
the air
i mean if a nuke goes up in the air man
that is rough on the environment they do
explode in the air they don't land
yeah nukes don't blow up they don't hit
the ground and blow up that would limit
the blast radius
nukes go right above the target and then
blow up blanketing down
wow dude the people who build these
these these weapons merchants of
death who knew how to maximize like
there's when they do
something with gravity bombs that's when
a plane drops a bomb so the first bombs
that were ever used the only ones were
called gravity bombs we flew a plane
over we dropped it
we also got icbms they they they they
did the math
they know exactly the maneuver you have
to do it's like it's like a 90 degree
or like a 270 degree turn or something
to maximize the escape
so the shock wave of the nuclear bomb
doesn't hit the plane
they calculate the stuff to a t to
maximize death that's horrifying that is
scary
i live on the water in san diego and i i
saw
a missile launch and i thought it was
russia nuking us because i'm right by
pendleton camp pendleton
and i went and i dove in my [ __ ] tub
because i'm sick i'm such a little girl
but but i found out later that it was uh
spacex i was like
elon could you give me a heads up i
almost [ __ ] my pants your mind went to
russia first
i swear to god it did wow do you think
that's because of media manipulation
yeah this was three years ago so of
course yeah
well the fear-mongering is very strong
and and you know the stuff you bring
about
you know some people would say it's
far-fetched some people wouldn't say but
but this is the stuff that we know about
there's other weapon systems that we
don't even know about that vladimir
putin even hinted at previously before
where he was talking about tsunami
weapons uh utilizing oceans in order to
take out you know coastal
infrastructure of major countries so you
know the levels of sophistication
when you describe merchants of debts it
doesn't just happen with nuclear weapons
it also happens in laboratories with
people creating
bio weapons in order to infect and hurt
and kill people as much as they can
which we know
a lot of countries have been working and
developing on viruses that
do affect people on their different
genomes uh on their
different genetic structures but on the
topic of merchants of death
i heard hillary clinton's in the news
too isn't she
all right so uh but we got to be we got
to be careful this one i'm not a fan of
the conspiracy theories to be honest
we have this story from 11 alive it came
out uh over the weekend you may have
seen it
alabama anchor who broke bill clinton
loretta lynch tarmac story is dead at 45
of an apparent suicide now if you're not
familiar with the story basically bill
clinton had a meeting with then attorney
general loretta lynch on a plane
and hillary clinton was under
investigation and the investigation gets
dropped then they bring it back up
and this forced loretta lynch to recuse
herself because of a conflict of
interest
this reporter christopher stein then
went on to write a book about it
and this was i was writing it last year
on like fox news this was back in what
was it 2016 when this story 2016.
when hillary clinton was running to be
president of the united states
and now i'll tell you this first and
foremost i i think the conspiracy theory
is silly
but people are pointing out the
conspiracy theory called the clinton
body count
where they're saying like look at all
these people connected to the clinton's
own man and so many have died and i
gotta say i just think it's bs
i really really do absolutely first of
all let me just point out in this story
first with respect to the guy's family
i i really don't like the idea that this
guy he's got family and kids
he was an anchor and now people you know
bring up conspiracy theories
but you know what people are a lot of
talk on the internet people are allowed
to ask questions they're
if they see patterns they're allowed to
ask questions about it and then we got
to investigate
this guy report on a story five years
ago five five years ago
a little bit longer than five years ago
why why if if there really was a
conspiracy what's clinton like i will
wait five years and then get my revenge
no oh yeah but but his book was just
released a year ago so
and that could have been the threat but
he said he received credible
threats against him that's true he said
that last year and he said the threats
have started
ever since he released that story he
also talked about how he had to move his
family
no multiple times because of these
threats he had
three young children he had a wife he
was 46 years old
prominently pretty young again i'm not
here jumping on any conclusions i'm not
going to tell you what happened i'm not
going to
say this happened exactly i'm just
saying some of the preliminary
data and information this is somewhat
causing a chilling effect and a lot of
people
are bringing up the fact that you know
hillary clinton's the clintons they
don't play by the rules
they're corrupted they were never held
accountable for their corruption
and who knows i mean another thing that
really kind of comes to mind right now
is bill clinton coming out and saying
that
the the netflix series house of cards is
99
and in house of cards in the first
season they assassinate and kill
journalists
but let me point this out what we're
talking about is the clinton body
conspiracy there's 46 people on that
list but it's not correct
so of course so so hold on this this guy
was getting death threats totally
believe it this sounds more like left
its extremists
who don't get held accountable who are
mad at the sky because they believe he
contributed to hillary clinton's loss
if the if the clintons were involved
they're not going to send him warnings
they're going to be like here's an email
just letting you know here's our plan
it's going to you know and look so about
there's this meme that goes around this
poster
it's like here are all the people the
clintons have been associated with the
clintons who have committed suicide
and some of them are completely it's
like six degrees of kevin bacon
it's like he was an accountant in a firm
that once consulted bill clinton and i'm
like come on dude yeah
so look look look high-profile political
people
are going to have tens or hundreds of
thousands of
of connections with various people and
these things might happen i'll tell you
this
i'm not saying i know for sure i'm
saying i err on the side of
show me the evidence and show me the
proof and i'll look through it for this
i think people jump the gun and the
biggest problem i have with any
conspiracy is
the moment you come out and say ah
clinton body count you've completely
discredit yourself in the eyes of anyone
who would actually do an investigation
anybody who would actually be who should
hear or ask questions or
if you want to inform people and you
come out you jump to the to the
conclusion
people are going to say okay you're nuts
what you say is hey
this guy was reporting on the clintons
this guy put out a big story
maybe he was working on another story he
was getting death threats
i think we should investigate it beyond
the claims of an apparent suicide
stop right there that's where we need to
go we do the investigation
but you know what i tell you this man
people need to understand
that the majority of premeditated murder
is never solved
the majority majority in illinois i
think it's like 53
so it's like they actually do a really
good job of tracking down a decent
amount but
most of it they can't solve i agree with
you we shouldn't be jumping to
conclusions at least
there should be an investigation uh and
but but you know there's some you know
serious questions that need to be asked
here
and i think i think every suicide is
investigated anyway so it should it
should be
the police are investigating this right
uh and then as far as the
the clinton body count there was uh i
think nbc las vegas
actually printed the the name of of the
list uh and then you know people who are
on
cbs cbs i think like barry seal vince
foster seth rich so again
uh as as you said doesn't causation does
not prove
you know correlation does not prove
causation doesn't mean it's true at
least we should investigate it
but uh you know you know i i think the
clintons
should be investigated hillary clinton
is the vhs
i'll make something very simple for you
if you come to me and you say tim
hillary clinton is an evil evil woman
who would not stop at killing to push
her political agenda you know what i'm
gonna say to you
muammar gaddafi yeah but foreign policy
is very difficult
he died exactly but foreign policy is
very different from a local journalist
in alabama who five years ago reported
on a story
came out with a book last year i really
doubt someone was like i'll get my
revenge five years later i just don't
see it i don't
you know what i think there's that often
when it comes to conspiracies people
overlook
simple solutions sure let me i'm trying
to be respectful this guy's family but
you know
with the people spreading the story
around i want to address it
here's a guy who broke one of the
biggest stories
in history five years ago a few years
later he writes a book
about the same story he broke four years
ago it's like
do you got anything else for us so now
maybe a year after the book
did it sell well maybe it didn't i don't
know maybe this guy
got to touch a piece of the sky and then
after five years he could not recreate
that moment
and maybe he got depressed he wouldn't
he he got he got he got to see over the
clouds you know what i mean yeah it's
it's not impossible i i always like to
look at the reporting on
what his co-workers had to say and i saw
some i read some tweets today that
they were saying you know this feels
surreal i was just cutting it up with
him
in the office last night they were
surprised
this is what you can't get carried away
with that's normal for suicides
but also yeah i get death threats you
know as well and let's acknowledge i bet
you'd probably get death threats as well
let's acknowledge it let's still work
on it let's be intellectually going to
be intellectually honest let me talk
about the
reserve i'll get it i'll get it coming
i'm going to live to be 100 years old
yeah
i uh i'm going to eat eat right and i'm
going to be very i'm very happy life's
great the business is booming you know i
got my friends here we're hanging out
never been happier i am not suicidal
at all for the record here uh testifying
in front of everyone i'll put my hand on
the bible if i have to
uh i love my life i i love uh
i love you know doing what i do but i
ever commit suicide
investigate hillary clinton
but this was a major story this did have
a huge impact on the elections
i think anything's possible here but but
i want to be again try to be respectful
to the family members
uh you know the the young children the
wife the friends uh
it's really up to them to speak here on
this matter i don't want to speak too
much on it
and i think at least there should be
more investigations and
and it does set a chilling effect so i
do think that this is possible do i have
the smoking gun do i have the proof
absolutely not
i don't claim to have but i think it is
possible that this happened because it
does set a chilling effect
that scares some people and i think it's
probably i think it's probable but but
we could get this simple
i think possible yeah but what's what's
possible it's possible for you to do a
backflip right now and and then break
your neck and fall
it's also possible from the fall too
listen exactly anything's possible
you can track youtube breakdowns youtube
mental breakdowns
all you got to do is look at look at a
youtuber track their views over the
month
and the moment you see a small dip in
their views will protest precipitate a
video where they're like i just can't do
this anymore but i can't it's too rough
not kidding
you'll watch their views and something
will happen where their views drop from
like a million per video down to like
800 down to 500
and then also the video drops i'm
quitting i can't take it anymore because
what happens is
they touch the sky and they touch the
sky and then every video after that is
them getting lower and lower and start
panicking saying
why can't i reach that anymore i saw
what was up there i
saw the beautiful reality and then they
break down and they do these videos
where they cry and they're like it's
just too you don't know how stressful it
is struggling every day and it's like
sometimes there are cycles in viewership
you got to calm down
but i've seen people lose their minds
lose their cool quit their channels
freak out
now you got a guy who with all due
respect he was a local anchor
and he comes out this is this is a big
jump he went from being a local anchor
to the biggest story probably in the
world
affecting political outcomes not only
that imagine he's saying he's getting
death threats
imagine how much awful stuff was sent to
him every day by these democrats
saying like you are scum you are violent
he reads it every day i'm sure
it was breaking him down yeah and and
he's being accused of being responsible
for
orange hitler for the past four years by
these nut cases yeah the blue and on
types so
yeah i can understand the pressure that
he was under it's just that just seemed
so much
it could be dude it could be both but
but there's a reason that the most
amount of sociopaths are in washington
dc
per capita and a lot of politicians are
cold-blooded killers that literally
bring
back slavery to africa you know and and
and they don't even care about it see
here's what happens hillary clinton
kills muammar qaddafi
not just that no no hold on hillary
clinton says about julia sanchez can't
we just drone the guy oh that was a joke
apparently
when you get a politician who laughs in
the face
of war with russia over the no-fly zone
in syria
people are going to go ahead and assume
that the simple solution is that she's a
lunatic who kills people
yeah i still don't i i just think it's
like why would this why would a super
villain like muck their hands up
in the nitty-gritty that matters nothing
you know what i mean
unless he's doing further research on
this story i don't i don't know i can't
even i can't even theorize honestly i
i think it's important for people's
worldview to see politicians as
sociopathic globalist clowns with a
monopoly of violence
in my own personal opinion but that's
just my own personal perspective here's
the truth
you don't need a clinton body count to
hate the clintons there's plenty of
evidence there's plenty of
corruption destroyed people in the
middle east because of the details too
so could you imagine if there was like
a uh you know like the uh uh a secretary
of state who ran a foundation that took
hundreds of millions of dollars from
foreign governments while they were
secretary of state i mean
like that couldn't possibly happen in
this country could it or hang out with
you know
the likes of jeffrey epstein and ditch
secret service and jump on the
i can't even say it the express uh
airplane
that they did with kevin spacey kevin
spacey also another person i i'd like to
bring these
things up because i think they're worth
it i think they're worth considering the
spacey body kit
but kevin spacey also has three people
that came out against him and accused
him of horrible things that we can't
mention in here on this youtube channel
when they were small children when they
were small children
they came out and said kevin spacey did
unspeakable things to them
three people who did that uh are dead as
well
uh kevin spacey you know house of cards
bill clinton i don't know
you can make a lot of jumps and
assertions here i'm not trying to do
that
i'm just saying uh you know there's a
reason there's so many sociopaths this
is what you
you got to be careful for right so i was
uh we had matt brainer on the show he's
the guy who's doing
uh he was doing the voter integrity
project and uh what he's doing now
look at look at america as it is so you
know one of the things he says is that
when it comes to like election issues
you get a lot of these
silly lawsuits that muck up the system
and make it really hard for the actual
hard like investigatory work and
reform work to fix these systems and
find you know fix these problems
that's why i'm very much like you start
with the evidence you have
and you seek in evidence and then you
find the conclusion when people come out
and they decide
i know it's this story it actually makes
it very difficult to
actually get an investigation or to to
solve whatever
actually happened in this regard i think
people should need to realize
we don't live in a movie i think
people's view of the world is very very
tainted by movies and i'll give you a
really simple
example silencers like people in big
cities don't think about guns literally
believe there's a thing you can screw
onto a gun and go pew pew pew
not a thing doesn't exist they believe
it so when it comes to these conspiracy
theories
it's like you got to understand how much
of your world view is tainted by movies
to think this stuff is possible like go
out
i tell you man go out to an actual
conflict urban conflict or war
it is so much different than these
people that anybody realizes because
movies tank their view of the world
i keep thinking about uh putin and i
think it was like five years ago
one of his political opponents was in a
car driving in moscow and they got
stopped on the street and dudes got out
and just shot him today on video yeah
yeah and so like in the united states
there's a lot of like death by suicide
we don't really hear of a political
opponent getting gunned down in their
car in the middle of the day in the
united states
but that doesn't mean it's not people
aren't getting killed for their politics
it's just saying we don't see that
blatant so when putin says ashley
babbitt was at an assassination no dude
when someone gets gunned down in their
car in the middle of the day that's
running against you
politically that's an assassination when
someone's trespassing
and gets killed that's not an
assassination
so don't be clear about that it was a
killing yeah it could be it's declared a
murder
should be more investigated and there
still should be some repercussions for
an officer
who shot an unarmed woman i'm just
waiting for the people that are
interested in ending police brutality
to have anything to say about ashley
abbott that would be [ __ ] amazing if
you guys could just have
one thing to say about her an unarmed
woman
shot in the neck at point blank range we
don't even know the guy's name still
i mean am i the only one that's bothered
by this i don't know well what's it when
it's an insurrectionist
okay so the other issue is we've been
having having an ongoing insurrection
from the far left for
for a long time now it's like i don't
even think it's fair to say a year
because it's been going on long before
that
when they would show up to a trump rally
and start attacking people throwing
explosives and beating people
when when were the democrats ever gonna
come out oh i'm sorry they said it was
an
idea jerry nadler oh it's just an idea
it's not real then you get
you like joy or and read or whatever
coming out and defending
saying you know antifa oh they're not
they're not bad people they're good guys
they're antifa it's just
the media absolutely protects them
here's what i'll say
they come out and they're like
republicans keep saying that it was just
tourists on on the sixth and i'm like
okay that's dumb
i don't care there were dumb people
rioting on the six auntie foe was bad as
well they riot
but the media acts like the only people
who exist are like three republicans who
say dumb things
that's it and then everyone else's voice
is shut out from the argument
yep and and everybody that protests for
black lives matter
whether they burn stuff or kill people
they're good and if you go to
the capitol and you uh you know get a
little bit aggressive with your
protesting
you're you are a terrorist and should
spend the rest of your years and get
yeah well they get bailed out
too yeah well yeah a lot of like blown
up
private property didn't seem to bother
people but as soon as it was public
property like
government property they went if you
remember the law last summer they were
talking about
you have insurance what are you upset
about you know that that was really
people's attitude
they were like of course if you built if
you have to burn down a building
to get people to pay attention to your
cause even if it's not a police precinct
it's a it's just some corner store
that's owned by
probably a black person in the
neighborhood it's i mean it's just the
uh
it's an excuse they don't actually want
to defend the people who live there
they just need an excuse for when
someone comes asking sure hey why did
you guys burn down that small corner
store
they got insurance okay that's it give
me an answer
so we got this story that's been going
viral and considering we're talking
about police brutality let's jump into
it
daily mail says moment five white
maryland police officers tase
and arrest black teenager after he
ignored warning to stop vaping on the
sidewalk
on the boardwalk so i don't know if you
guys saw this the video is actually
really straightforward it's just like
this kid he's walking down the boardwalk
they tell him it's not vacant vaping
stop
he puts his hands up and then when he
goes take his backpack off they just
tase him and he goes down and they jump
on him
people are freaking out it's not the
most egregious video
in terms of police retaliator black
lives matter but i'll make sure to get
your guys thoughts on this as a more you
know libertarian
view of these things i'll say right now
two things
they shouldn't have done it obviously
the dude went
and reached to put his backpack off but
you see his hand go behind his back
cop probably thought he was going for
something or he's not gonna risk whether
or not he was
he thought it was possible and it was a
taser he wasn't he wasn't killing him
yeah honestly of all the things i've
seen it's probably one of the least
egregious
even though i hate it and i think it's
absurd that you would be um enforcing a
law like that
i i can't get all in an uproar over this
one in particular just because
yes he did reach like i could i can
understand from the cops perspective
especially since he's not using lethal
force i can understand that one
the one that really bothered me was that
cop i don't remember what state it was
in
but for speeding and and flipped the
woman
pregnant woman he pits a pregnant woman
at like 55 miles per hour
that one infuriated when she's trying to
pull over safely at an
exit because there was uh hazards on
yeah i mean
yesterday driving here i had a truck uh
hit my uh rv
and my rv was serving everywhere i'm
like there's no way i'm pulling on the
side here i had to wait
two miles uh and then luckily a good
samaritan told me
you know what happened and was a witness
but but again like stopping on the
highway is extremely dangerous a lot of
people die
doing this this woman was trying to do
the right thing she put her hazards on
slowed down and was showing that she was
going to pull over
a pregnant woman and this police officer
without any care without any
consideration
just does this maneuver flips her car
over and no charges
no charges the most damning part when he
gets out of his vehicle after she's
upside down he walks towards her without
even pulling his weapon
he is not at all afraid for his life why
are you using lethal force if you're not
afraid for your life and then he
and he can get an answer and then he
talks her down he's like why didn't you
stop
she's like i was trying she was like you
should have done it earlier and i'm like
are you
kidding me unbelievable the level of
disrespect the level i mean
there's so many stupid laws out there
someone wants to do let them douche
flute but these interactions are
unnecessary if someone's
literally outside do fluting with their
vape let them do it
i don't care it doesn't bother me like
are you saying about
the police i'm saying so you're saying
private sector get rid of all cops
that's what you're saying is listen
so you're saying you want to abolish all
the police i'm not a fan
of using force and having the monopoly
of violence
to enforce the absolute stupidest laws
especially when it comes to lockdowns
especially when it comes to restrictions
a lot of people
even on the right even trump supporters
are waking up even ezra levant
of all people he's coming out and he's
like full almost
all right he's full almost a cab almost
there and he's going crazy he's the
rebel guy in canada he's like
and he's sort of love police officers he
used to be like he used to be the
biggest back of the blue guy
and then people have to acknowledge
there's a big contradiction between the
back the blue
and the people who believe in the
constitution there's a big contradiction
that people need to wake up to
right didn't paul joseph watson used to
make videos like against police
brutality
like back in the day alex jones prison
planet one two and three
and then they came out with you know
being full trump supporters and backing
the blue
what was it what was that which is a big
flip which which they deserve some
criticism on
but they get picked on enough uh to be
honest and
and they don't deserve you know a lot of
the criticism that they get
but they do deserve that criticism if
you have the whole deep state against
you you can't also have
the cops against you you've got to pick
one of these is the king are the
canadians is the difference between back
the blue and back the monarchy
is that am i off base yeah like you
don't have to back the monarchy to back
the blue and you don't have to hate the
police to hate the monarch no i think in
canada it's it's they're red
they're mounties right they're wearing i
don't know it's didn't they they didn't
they right
and they ride moose right definitely
they ride
if you really want to be infuriated you
start watching the police videos and
encounters that are happening in canada
people showing up to people's homes
because they have a foreign car in their
driveway
people showing up to businesses shutting
them down people going to churches
arresting pastors that are practicing
their religion
what's happening in canada i believe was
designed
to happen in the united states and it
only didn't happen because of a few
states
that stood up for their rights florida
being one of them
texas that followed suit but truly
florida and this is this is an
understatement and it's not just because
i'm wearing the t-shirt
uh that i have that i sell myself but
florida truly
i i believe the bigger statement here
that they made
is far more significant than we give
credence to
because what they did is essentially
prove how lockdowns are pointless
well you know people are saying people
are going to be dropping dead all over
in florida
there's going to be mass graves in
florida the whole population is going to
die in florida
none of that happened and it proved that
the lockdowns were alive from the very
beginning
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
i'll explain this to a lot of people so
to all my to all my liberal friends who
are pro-gun control who don't understand
because they like to come out these
facebook
comments where they're like what do you
think you're gonna do go to war with the
government you're so dumb
the first thing i'll say is vietnam and
afghanistan uh yes
simple arms are effective against a
tyrannical government or
just an oppressive force regardless but
no i i don't think
anyone's going to go to war against the
government i hope they don't i just
think that
when the police officers go knocking on
bretta taylor's house
and they kick the door in and then
brianna taylor's boyfriend
hears someone breaking in and fires in
defense the charges against him get
dropped
that's literally what happened why
because you have a right to keep and
bear arms
and should you believe that you are
being you intruded upon your right to
defend yourself so those charges got
dropped
in the united states when the police
want to serve a warrant they have to
contend with the fact that they may be
entering the home of someone who is
armed if you be very careful about how
they do it make sure they have the
proper warrants
and the legal authority to go up against
someone who may be armed
in canada where they don't they kick the
door in beat the wife
and drag the guy out of the house it's
not about going to war
it's about just having a more even
playing field where the police are
obligated to respect the process it's a
deterrent
and respect to the individual the
respect of the human being in canada
they banned
a large portion of firearms right before
the whole covet 19 lockdown that also
needs to be acknowledged australia
also got rid of people's ability to
defend themselves
and to have firearms also some of the
most strictest
lockdowns in the entire world australia
canada
and now they're trying to do it here in
the united states you're telling me that
they banned weapons before they tried to
implement tyranny
there's a historical precedent for that
it's crazy it's the
british commonwealth that's where this
is happening it's terrifying and that's
why
at least one former element of the
british commonwealth was like uh
we should have guns and then the crown
was like nah you got to give up your
guns and they were like no dude they're
like then we're going to go
you know attack you and then they fought
back it is embarrassing to watch biden
interact with like g7 and stuff but man
watching the queen is like just
delusional she's like hobbling humped
over can barely move like this is the
leader of the
of britain this is it well the empire
certainly has uh
come a long way to put it mildly well
she's a representative figure that you
know always has
i came and say the words here she has
people like jimmy seville
uh edward heath jeffrey epstein always
around her family members prince andrew
yeah yeah that's their relatives is
there really any more
a empty figurehead than biden at this
point honestly the royal family being
connected to individuals who
do unspeakable things to children is far
too extensive not to mention here
uh and it's absolutely truly disgusting
to see the the the
incr how weird is that reports are the
things i want to say i can't say on this
they're so powerful it's the like the
one of the largest land owning families
on earth i think is the
is the family oh like the catholic
church yeah they own a ton of land all
over the place right yeah i think so i'd
have to look is it like the largest
landowner in manhattan trinity church
something like that i don't know or one
of the largest i thought it was ccp
china and new york i don't know i
wouldn't be surprised to be completely
honest
there's been a huge influx of chinese
capital into the american relationship
oh yes yeah didn't you didn't texas
like someone's trying to in texas ban
the purchasing of land by chinese
nationals or something like that or the
chinese communists
isn't it kind of weird that we allow
that in the first place i was talking to
an accountant and they were saying
something about like
foreign nationals can start a business
in the united states
you don't need to be a citizen then
they'll use that business to grant
themselves
citizenship they'll they'll use them and
say oh i work for this company and i
need to come to united states and
they'll use that
that seems kind of crazy to me that the
world here's how the world works if
you're rich you can do whatever you want
seriously in mexico i still can't buy
real estate though so there there are
there are
i can't it has to be held in uh some
sort of like
trust or llc or something i think i
think brazil might be similar yeah
many many countries have that because
the americans with all their wealth were
coming in and buying up all the prime
real estate so why don't we do that
well i think that i mean we we just
first off we have more capital than most
foreigners at least we did historically
so we didn't have to
worry about someone from brazil coming
in and out bidding an american because
they didn't have the kind of income they
did
but now the playing field is being
leveled where there are you know
many many billionaires across the globe
so they can buy whatever they want let
me
let me let me tell you guys a story so i
i applied for a mortgage and
i talked about this last week but i
think with you know clinton here
uh i applied for a mortgage months ago
to to get a small house nothing nothing
too crazy expensive like actually just
small
uh single family i think it's like two
bedroom two bath and
the first weird thing that happened was
they started juggling agents on me
agent kept changing they kept demanding
the same paperwork
over and over and over again it was like
hey we need your pay stubs hey we need
your tax return
hey we need they asked me to write a
letter hand write a letter explaining my
job and my business and what i do and
i'm like okay this is getting weird
and then finally for three months they
come back and say oh your credit score's
too low
my credit score is impeccable it is
almost as high as it could possibly be
my income is fantastic and it was very
strange it denied this
but what it seems like you almost went
full trump there i thought you're gonna
go
tremendous tremendous uh but talking to
my family and friends they're like
it seems like they're trying to stop us
from buying property
meanwhile blackrock right many other
investment firms wall street pension
funds are buying up property and
outbidding people
so i i don't understand why it is that
they did
they went through all this and uh gave
us the run around
but you know what i said i was on the
phone with this with this company i'll
leave them nameless for now
i they were like look i was like hey you
know the information you claimed about
my credit score is false
and defamatory and i actually want to
know how this happened because if you
guys issue false credit statements
that could seriously impact my ability
to buy property and it's
not true and i want this corrected
immediately this lady is like let me
find someone for you and i was thinking
about it i was like why would
a lender do something like this
unless they couldn't admit they didn't
have liquidity
to actually issue loans or they were
near insolvency
and so i sat on the phone i was like is
your company
nearing insolvency no no no absolutely
not i was like i just find it
interesting how long and hard i've been
struggling with with the the run around
you know to try and get this alone i
just kind of feels like something must
be wrong behind the scenes and they
don't want to publicly admit it like
they may be nearing insolvency no no no
um actually you know
i'm going to put you on hold for a
minute and see if i can find someone and
they put me on hold for like 15 minutes
i was like i wonder if i struck a chord
you know i'm making assumptions
but i have to wonder i started thinking
about this there's a year
no one paying mortgages is it possible
that all of these people who had loans
did not pay them back because they
couldn't and the bank is sitting on
bad debt well black one things
blackrock's buying is more
mortgage-backed securities
same thing that they did in 2008 is
there they're buying up massive amounts
of them
i just rather you actually you said you
had some expertise in the whole thing
like why would someone with good credit
be get denied alone in this day and age
well
there's there's a multitude of factors
when it goes to conventional lending
i was in the private lending field so
basically as a hard money broker
i i took private investor capital and i
would lend it out to real people so like
i'm the actual guy who cares basically
what banking used to be and what it
should be
is someone in the in the middle that
cares about the capital on one side and
the borrower on the other because
they want to pair it together they don't
want to get sued they want everything to
work out
in the end and the investor gets a
return that they can appreciate
however with the the uh conventional
lending side
it's complete nonsense they're the
basically it's just so deeply regulated
that you can have these these
these windows that you have to fit
through perfectly or you can get turned
down
and this is a complete opposite of what
it used to be in 2004 2005 whereas if
you had a pulse at that point you could
get qualified for a million dollar loan
and you could just lie about your income
it didn't matter it's now completely the
opposite
now okay go ahead i had a loan with them
already yes and i got along with them
recently within the past i think like
eight months
the only thing i could think of i mean
you
if you're right and they're insolvent i
would be stunned simply because
the federal reserve has no i don't
really think they're insolvent
right i'm just saying i wonder if
they're saying on bad debt so they're
like what do we do we got all these
loans that no one's paying
back blackrock comes in and starts
buying up all these houses
could it be that that's a pseudo bailout
when people all start trying to sell
their homes because they couldn't pay
for them and then blackrock comes in and
covers the debt
plus i look at it from a totally
different uh
perspective actually the the inventory
is so low across the country
right now there's uh last i looked there
was only a million houses for sale
normally there's four to six million
which would be a
standard clearing time of about six
months so we have
one to two months worth of inventory the
prices are skyrocketing simply because
the demand outpaces supply
it's not there's no conspiracy there
however the reason we have that
situation is because of the foreclosure
and eviction moratoriums which are
a product of the lockdowns which the
government is responsible for and then
the fed
is juicing the system by putting seven
trillion dollars
out there and of course you're going to
ch you're gonna you're gonna be forced
to chase yield
in a way that is very reckless and we
are we are laying the groundwork for the
greatest real estate bubble in our
history
i promise you that and give it four or
five years
at most in my opinion you could go to
liberty lockdown you could tell me if
i'm wrong
four to five years from now but be very
cautious so are you saying people
shouldn't be well you're not
giving advice but you think it's dumb to
buy a house right now
i think it's it's sane in the short term
because inventory is so low and the
regulatory environment is so challenging
to be able to build
it's gonna be it's going to be a year
plus before you get these
huge waves of housing and then you also
because of the lockdowns you you
destroyed the supply chain so you have
all of these shortages and materials
which is
ultimately adding to the price of real
estate because that's what it costs to
build it yeah so they're
all the way around though this is what
bothers me about i saw this this clip
that was really it was a great clip
it was tucker carlson with this uh this
reporter guy that
did it did a really eloquent takedown of
all this
but ultimately in all of his soliloquy
did not mention the federal reserve once
the federal reserve is responsible
for so much that is destroying this
country right now
and it doesn't get any talk like none
and it's and it's
it's frustrating to me because it seems
as if you almost get into alex jones
territory when you bring up the federal
reserve no
it is a legalized cabal of bankers that
control this
i mean the world but moreover this
country and this economy but hey they're
lgbtq and non-binary friendly as they
announced recently so
uh they're perfect for criticism so what
you're saying clint is that you're a
bigot
well you know no no i'm on your team no
hold on tim i would counter your
narrative because i don't think
blackrock would do anything for the
benefit
of the united states especially with
their record with their history
of getting bailouts whenever they have
losses and
keeping the profits whenever they have
profits this is what blackrock
is and we have to remember in 2008 that
large huge
economic reckoning was just the burp was
just
a small bubble a part of a larger
indigestion problem
that there's no pet no business fall for
and
this is only going to be so much more
worse because in 2008 this larger
problem wasn't rectified wasn't fixed
it was paid over with more debt with a
bigger bubble
and that bubble's going going to pop
sooner or later the only thing you
needed to do
was let the bad actors fail that's all
you had to do
and they refused and what do we have now
the the most egregious
moral hazard in history you have
blackrock and all of these other guys
and going out so let's not forget bill
gates the largest
landowner in all of the united states
families
of course and so so they're going out
and they're buying real estate at any
price because they can't find yield
because the stock market is also in a
bubble because of the trillions that the
fed is printed
and now you have young people who are
priced out of housing that feel hopeless
that are suicidal you've also locked
them in their [ __ ] house for a year
so i don't even blame them for feeling
suicidal
and none of this gets blamed on the fed
we could have never locked down this
country for a year
if not for the federal reserve because
you couldn't have papered it over like
you did
so every single layer of this falls at
the [ __ ] doorstep of the federal
reserve and no one talks about it
so drives me crazy so what you're saying
is uh buy bitcoin
yes actually i am yeah i am saying that
well i'm good if there's a bubble like
you're saying a six year bubble from now
housing bubble what would it look like
year by year what would change it's very
hard to say because
it all right so this is this is what i
tell people when they ask me for advice
because i am
a long-time real estate investor
it's very important that you pay
attention to short-term interest rates
obviously if the federal reserve hikes
rates we're in serious trouble so i
don't think they're going to do it
simply because they can't
they cannot do it because our debt is so
massive if they increase the rates at
which the government has to borrow we
are insolvent as a nation
so the alternative is that you see
bondage bond vigilantes come in
and they they stop buying long-term uh
bonds in which case you see interest
rates hike
basically all i'm saying is this if you
see 30-year mortgages or
15-20 whatever that get north of
four and a half five percent expect to
see the fissures that are
underlying this economy start to really
show so what does it look like in four
years it depends on the interest rates i
mean it really does like this is why i i
keep federal reserve sets well they do
when they don't they set
short-term interest rates long-term
interest rates are set by bond buyers
bond buyers are china the american
people many people buy bonds so
it's not it's not as simple as that
people always think like well if they
hike rates or if they don't hike rates
this this lasts forever
no because at some point housing no
matter how cheap it is because you can
you can get you know three percent
30-year money well we have an inflation
rate of five percent what
logical sense does that make as an
investor why would you ever
lend out money at less like basically
slightly more than half of the inflation
rate you are assuring yourself capital
destruction
and yet people are doing it but the
reason they do it is because they
believe that the federal reserve will be
the buyer of last resort
when it comes to those bonds that's the
reason that it persists they're
expecting a bailout
yes they are and it's a good bet and
they should yes and they should
yep and and they and the fed should
expect a revolution
if i have anything to say about it i
don't i don't i don't know i think
they'd be smart
peaceful no i think most people most
people are just going to grumble and
demand a higher
minimum wage well they're the fools yeah
they're the useful idiots because
if you still think that that's the
reason that you're not getting paid well
enough and that's the reason you can't
afford a house
all of this is a product of your
currency being destroyed year after year
for a hundred dollars you know what
really blows my mind about bitcoin is
like every time i tweet about it i get
someone who's arguing from 2011 like is
it as if they got into a time machine
or like if they fell asleep under a tree
and grew a really long beard and woke up
and opened twitter
and then commented i'm like bro it's
been 10 years
i put money into bitcoin like six years
ago i'm very happy with my store of
value
yeah well it's not a currency i don't
care right if i put money my money in
the bank i would have lost half of it by
now or whatever the stupid number is
the actual number of of inflation so i
bought bitcoin
wish i bought more and they're like yeah
well look it fell 50
bro i bought in november it's up 300 and
something percent stop
looking at it and and it's it's it's
it's insane okay i'll tell you what
go put your money in the us dollar cause
the story i always tell everybody i went
on amazon
clicked a little table i was like i need
a tablet for the house forgot to buy it
a few days later i opened up amazon and
said
alert i clicked it price change for this
product jumped up 130 bucks
amazing that's a huge huge shift it's
incredible was it like a 15
increase in cost or something while
bitcoin went up 15 percent in value
so we we have a shed full of wood left
over from the skate parks
and it's probably like i'm sitting on a
gold mine yeah yeah it's like 10 grand
seriously it's like it's it's out there
no no joke it is a shed full of wood and
lumber
of various sizes fantasy at the time
at the time it was probably a thousand
dollars it's probably like six seven
thousand dollars of lumber right now
what has it been like as a builder
i was just gonna say i'm building six
houses right now fortunately we started
buying
our our materials as the planning was
getting near the you know the
vertical stage where you start to
actually build but yeah i'm getting
crushed
i'm getting crushed but the fortunate
thing for me is the end market will end
up paying me off anyways because the
market has increased
so much it's up 15 percent year over
year nationwide
in san diego it's even higher than that
uh florida
like basically any of the red states
where people have have fled the blue
states
to you know go and have some semblance
of freedom the market some of those
markets are up
fifty seventy five percent i was just in
florida and i was trying to help a
friend and some family members find
anything there it's virtually freaking
impossible right now because the prices
are just going up
so high i was just flabbergasted
and all these real estate guys are like
yup this is utterly insane i have never
seen this uh high of demand
i heard one guy saying it's gonna go
down in 16 months other people are
saying no that's not going to happen but
but
it's virtually impossible and at the
bitcoin conference which was also
happening
in florida in miami there was a lot of
talk about the federal reserve about the
banking cartel that's why i loved
them and there was 12 000 people with
with all these conversations going along
and the big conversation was we need to
get away from this financial tyranny
that's happening right now that you know
inflation is a tax on savings if you're
stuck you know having us dollars
in your hands or underneath your bed
those dollars are
slowly liquidating those dollars are
slowly going away and you don't even
realize it the purchasing power of the
dollar look up that chart
go on duckduckgo click purchasing power
of
dollar and click images and you will be
shocked come on man
you know we're not raising taxes on
anybody unless you make more than
four hundred thousand dollars families
it's only
four hundred thousand dollars meanwhile
we're going to
print seven trillion and we're gonna
borrow 20 something trillion and pump it
into the system which will devalue all
of your savings
and strip away your resources and buying
power without you even realizing it
because if you did realize it
you'd probably go outside with a
pitchfork part of a bigger problem a
part of a bigger
uh solution which is brought to us by
the g7 recently
with their build back uh better proposal
which they announced that they're going
to try to get 40 trillion dollars
on infrastructure and as we know the
term infrastructure
very loose term very generalized term
but when when you see the government
intervene
so dramatically when you see them print
money out of thin air
we have to understand the american
people need to wake up to the fact that
when this happens
they are getting robbed blind and the
government is literally coming to your
house
as you're sleeping going through your
money taking it from you slapping your
wife upside the head kicking your dog
and saying
give me more and then american people
are like yeah sure yeah yeah give us
more
and then it's just there's this meme
going around that that i shared
today of a clown saying hey we're going
to give you free stuff and then he opens
up this
this prize box and it's a gun to the
person's head
because that's essentially what it is
when you get promised free stuff it's
your servitude
it's your financial tyranny it's you
being robbed blind
naked uh to the point where people are
finding it extremely difficult to make
ends meet
and harder and harder to own anything
and this again plays into this bigger
great reset agenda which is
essentially carried out with the same
generic talking points of build back
better which is all these globalists
keep repeating and talking about
isn't bacon up like 20 percent that
sounds right yeah
every year lumber's up 400 i mean this
is this is
wild stuff but bacon well yeah i know
bacon's more important but
uh no it's true and you know peter
schiff is wrong about bitcoin but he's
right about this
he's right that not his analogy used to
be
that america is a heroin addict and debt
is our
is our heroine i would like to add to
his analogy and say that
it's actually the globe that's where
that's where we are now
because we went from i think it was 19
trillion before
trump and national debt we're
approaching 30 trillion by the end of
this year
i estimate personally even though the c
the cbo says it'll be 40 trillion by the
end of 2030
i think it'll probably be closer to 50
trillion nationally we have over
not naturally globally we have over 200
trillion in debt unfunded liabilities in
america are about 100 trillion
i mean you go down the list and it's
like this is such it's so clearly a
house of cards and the most important
thing i want people to understand is
it's not
[ __ ] new it's not new the savings
alone crisis
the tech bus the 0809 bus even
even before i was born we have the the
entire purpose of the federal reserve
is that you can have malinvestment and
then at the end of the day you can bail
yourself out
and who who is actually bailing yourself
out we are the people that pay taxes not
these sons of [ __ ] that are profiting
and taking billions
that's that's really the the scam here
and and
because we don't understand it we have
people that we have the marxists that
think that it's it's capitalist greed
that's the issue
and you have the republicans who think
that it's immigration that's the issue
and that's why they can't get ahead and
that's why they can't own a home you're
both wrong
you're both seeing a portion of the
elephant you're not seeing the whole
thing
i want to add the debt to that analogy
as i have eloquently before
and i would say the federal reserve is a
toothless crack [ __ ] on fentanyl
to add to all of this uh a part of the
larger context and when you start seeing
things from that perspective
that actually makes sense that's
offensive to crack [ __ ] though yeah i
apologize
these are people who who need help and
compassion the federal reserve is like
you ever see that subreddit evil
buildings it's just
oh yeah someone should put the fed on
that subreddit just a picture of the
federal reserve
each and every one the sad thing is i
don't think many people would get the
joke
they wouldn't even recognize the
building full building i like i would
say that the the debt
federal reserve debt is the heroine and
then the interest on the debt is the
methadone
yeah you need to get off the heroin but
unfortunately in this situation
you it's their methadone so if they
don't want you to have it and the reason
the metaphor works so well is because
ultimately the debt the the heroin
you're taking
you have to take more and more just to
not get sick that's where we exist today
and and the reason that the collapse in
0809
was so severe is because the debt was
significant at that point
we have no idea what is coming with this
next collapse i am telling you
because the debt is so much more uh you
know
just severe than it was even 10 years
ago and there was
there is no paul volcker that exists in
politics today that's going to come in
and do the right thing
and hike interest rates to 22 like he
did in 1981 it's not
it's not gonna happen and i know that
seems crazy because we've existed with
three and a half percent mortgages
this i'm talking about fed funds rate
was over 20 percent
that dude is a animal and what it was
what what happened with that i mean
people stopped buying or what two years
severe recession
and then we had 30 years of the greatest
economic boom in
human history he's a hero for that he's
a bad guy in a lot of other ways but
what he did with that was incredible
because 70s were very much like what
we're experiencing now
high inflation and he was like we ain't
playing this
he's a bit he's a builder burger king i
had a very interesting conversation
because he was lost in the building and
i was trying to help him find his way to
the vip area as i was questioning him
about bill defer
he seemed super stoked about it he was
really nice
he was actually a very cordial guy and
he actually let me in the room to ben
bernanke and i went up to ben bernanke
and i asked him how does it feel to
steal the most amount of money in
recorded human history from
the working class and he literally tried
to rip away the microphone from my hands
you're officially my hero you actually
gotta i'll send you the video yeah
we are changed ben bernanke there's like
three confrontations he gets really
angry when he gets confronted also a
bilderberg member just a side note
when you bernanke yes you went skydiving
with remember oh yes we
and me and and tim made a video about
ben bernanke because
people are like there's no way you're
confronting all these guys this is
impossible
so luke was accused of being a spy like
working for
a bunch of like dick cheney and tony
blair
because luke was able to confront
bernanke like in a private event
so there were all these posts on reddit
there were like it's no there's no way
this is possible
luke is controlled opposition so uh we
put together a video where luke's on the
phone
or like no you're chilling and your
phone rings yeah and i think i think
your brother made the photoshop images
of me and ben bernanke with strippers
and skydiving
so what happens is luke's luke's sitting
there and then his phone
rings and it's like it says ben bernanke
and he's like benny what's up
and then the camera's panning to like
background stuff and there's a there's a
photoshop of of luke and ben bernanke
skydiving together
and then he's like yeah i need some more
what did you call them uh federal
reserve fiat
slave notes or something and you're like
i'm going to say you're slapping it with
all these
yeah yeah i'll just i'll pretend to
question you you'll act flustered it'll
be great we'll make a bunch of money
bernanke said that there was no chance
of a housing collapse about 18 months
before it happened
yeah but you know why [ __ ] genius
they want people
to they want the poor people to keep
buying you're absolutely
they're sneaking out the back door
absolutely right that's that's the
mistake that people make is they always
assume
how could they be so bad isn't it their
job to evaluate economics
how could they have gotten this wrong
because it's the that's what they're
there to do
they're there for you to be the buyer of
uh that holds the bag
while all of their crony [ __ ] get
out the back door that's what it's
always been
and yet we allow this to persist i just
want to really emphasize this point
why are we allowing this to persist it's
basic
if you because you've got republicans
who sit on their hands and democrats who
set things on fire i don't think
they don't know it's ignorance it's like
it's like it's like intentional
obfuscation there's this henry ford
quote i came across it's well enough
that people of the nation do not
understand our banking and monetary
system for if they did i believe there
would be a revolution before tomorrow
morning yes that was like the
30s or 20s or something it's been going
on since they formed the federal reserve
basically that's a good question
arguably even before i think uh andrew
jackson was terrified he broke up the
central bank in the 1850s and got an
assassination attempt against jefferson
advised against it as well
so they put his face on another bill
yeah
he said that he said that uh national
banks would be more dangerous than a
standing army i mean
these guys got it they got it because
this isn't new that's what i keep going
back to it's not new it has happened and
it's lasted
far far before the federal reserve the
federal reserve was just the best at it
and damn were they good at it because
they got it done in the dead of night
and no one knew about it and they have
been doing it for 110 years that's right
good for
them yeah it's just raw talent and
ability i applaud you and
and with that being said let's go to
super chat if you haven't already give
that like button a nice little tap
and thank you to everybody who's
subscribed to this channel hit the like
button and
share the show you don't got to like us
or think we're the best but if you think
we're at least better than cnn
we need your help because youtube props
them up puts them on the front page
share the video on whatever social media
you can share the show and
word of mouth really helps greatly
appreciate it
let's see what we got over on this year
super chats we got
apc doc says if you attack biden you
attack the
you know the thing trying to know the
pressure indeed
acme products says donation to the
homeless polish fund
that's uh luke i i i have some i have
some very important
news for everybody um that needs to be
it needs to be said
luke can't drive man i don't even this
guy's trying to pull a trailer in
and i'm like luke turn the wheel to the
left and then luke turns the wheel to
the right
i'm like what are you doing and you're
like and then i'm like turn left and he
goes straight i'm like oh man i can't
even i left i walked away i was smiling
as i was doing it
and now the trailer's in like a weird
position like at an angle and like
sideways but you know
and i'm okay are you rving the nation by
yourself you got people with you
by myself pretty much yeah i'm awesome
all right let's see
bobby lane says i snap luke in the house
elizabeth carmela comedian says we know
luke is there the jig is up show us
proof of life
here he is josh arces hey guys i'm
really enjoying cast castle tim your
treadmill should be facing the window
tim pool on rollerblades on a conveyor
belt speeding towards a huge pane of
glass
might not always end well i i really
didn't think people would get a kick out
of that as much as they did
so i i put i put uh new uh bearings and
some wheels and roller blades
and they were kind of stiff so i was
like i want to break them in so i just
started
on the treadmill and uh kent who films
filmed me do it and then i jokingly was
like
you know most people run on the
treadmill till they can get you know a
few miles in
oh i saw that yeah i just stand there
and i get the same amount of distance
yeah
i'm working smart and then i guess
people thought it was really funny so
james alford says welcome back luke no
luke we puke
all right mexican american conservative
says luke your dad valade is a savage
lol two counties in nevada go
constitutional and not complying with
federal or state
conservatives we do look a lot a lot a
lot alike
oh i i think i think we got some good
advice here never summer says tim
pull a kathy bates on luke's ankles and
lock him in the studio so he can never
leave us again that sounds good
do you know that's a reference to no was
it called
that's a great scene by the way whoa
look at this paul's to the wall podcast
says
tim i live next to the chemtool fire the
black smoke cloud trailed over 100 miles
our local news told us to wear a mask
can't make this up also i'm happy to see
liberty locked under the podcast clint
is the real deal yes
i've been on their show so this is this
is some inside baseball very cool
skizbot says tim that luke hologram
can't give to can give tupac a run for
his money
yeah luke's actually not here in fact
luke's been a hologram the whole time
that's right pre-programmed all right
yeah ai pre-programmed
powered ai very high level that's pretty
good very realistic
luke rodkowski is my daddy says you will
live in the cabin
you will harvest the deer meat you will
eat the animal organs you will own the
guns
i will probably be doing another
survival apocalypse training event
sometime in the near future just a heads
up on that we
we we had a deer and he's he's pushing
it he like
the other night i was walking outside on
the phone and he was just standing there
like 20 feet away from just staring at
me and i'm like
yeah i started yelling at him and then
he just like
you know kind of like flinched at me
these are gangsters i was in key west
they had these miniature deers that you
can't really do anything with
and they were just there was one
standing outside just looking at me
like the whole time i i tried to like
scare it nothing to fight and then i got
atlas out and then we like
i i we went for a run and the deer was
just there
and then like 10 other deer came out
the next time and just like started
walking i'm like i'm i'm done you know
what sentence i did not expect to hear
tonight
dears are gangsters yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah incredible
so i have i have news about the chickens
too so we thought one of our chickens
was transgender
because they were all assigned female at
birth we went to a hatchery
and the guy said they're all females
okay well
one day and they're like 15 weeks
the only the only thing that was a sign
that this one chicken was actually
a rooster was the the wattle was growing
faster than the others
other than that it was behaving very
much like a hen until
just this past week when it started
crowing
and i thought so i looked it up i said i
have chickens once crowing and all the
articles were basically like
you get an alpha hen when there's no
rooster they'll like sometimes nominate
a boss hen who starts crowing and act
like a rooster
and because the crowing was not good
crowing it was like
i was like okay that's not like a good
rooster
but it's a young rooster i guess and so
it turns out
it probably is just a rooster so i took
a picture and some people asked we
called the farm guy and he's like well
you know
sometimes we get it wrong i was like
okay so the reality is
this poor rooster was assigned female at
birth
and we were raising it as a female as a
hen and it turns out it's actually a
dude
a lot with what we talk about here on
the show it does it's interesting how
that works out it should run for
governor of california
so now so now i guess we just have a
rooster so she was a he the whole time
yeah we think so far wow yeah they can
get it right life is twisted
hey how about them it's weird right all
right let's see we got
jonathan galterini says i love you tim
but luke is so much fun when he's on
here live lol we miss you luke lol
i'm i'm reading all of the ones where
they're kissing luke's butt so that he
stays
yay it's luke i hope he stays i'm
suspicious
here's here's a super chat from john
smith luke is the greatest of all time
the show only functions because of luke
please luke never leave us again
and luke you're just so awesome dude
he's been on his phone this whole time i
think he's sending these
i've been i've been tweeting a lot i
just i just i just made that last one
john smith yeah
yeah all right let's see hayden says was
it smart to sell all my crypto by 40
acres of forest
only things that seem valuable to me
anymore is land crypto precious metals
off and things for survival only one i
kept was the decent amount of doge i
picked up in march
i think bitcoins website my personal
opinion what are you going better than
doctors what do you think clint like
what's the diversity of assets into
into owning property and owning crypto
for you personally and not advice for
others yes this is not advice for others
because that would be
crazy um i think that because
real estate is so tied to leverage i i
think it's really a dangerous investment
honestly even though
even though i could see in the year or
two i could still see price appreciation
at some point the the chickens are going
to come home to roost and make weird
noises like
tim's turns out they're roosters yeah
all right
so i prefer crypto so you say rent and
store crypto and then
after the bubble bursts i mean yeah i
actually this is this is the most
anti-libertarian floss or you know
stance will take tonight
i think that you should be holding some
cash because if the
if and when the collapse comes that
ability to buy deflated assets will be
the opportunity of your lifetime
and if you don't have any liquidity you
will regret it and as you saw
during the lockdowns when they were
first announced if you had wanted to
pivot from crypto into the stock market
because the stock market got crushed
guess what also got crushed crypto did
yeah i remember being in zimbabwe and
people being like i wish i had cash i
wish i had
money and then the huge run on the banks
they couldn't get it
and things in the supermarket were just
going up you know incredibly at the time
and
that's a big learning lesson that i
learned yeah you got to diversify both
ways
gen z says tim no one ever brings up
that florida has red flag laws
and pa possible republican governor dan
laflin
is for raising minimum wage he's a fraud
you got red flag laws down there make
america florida what are you doing i
haven't
looked into it but other i mean getting
rid of
core components of critical race theory
when i came down there they also
eliminated
restrictions on the second amendment
they got rid of lockdowns they got rid
of mask mandates they got
they they you know made sure there's
going to be no vaccine passports
what they're doing is absolutely huge i
don't know exactly to the reference of
what the commenter said but otherwise
what i've been seeing is incredible
great things from florida
all right we got brian marcinski says
hey tim just wanted to give a massive
shout
to our to the firefighters that came to
relieve us for the night at the fire in
rockton illinois
we'll probably probably be back at
tomorrow uh you guys
firefighters across the country and the
firefighters right now you know you guys
rock you guys are heroes and thank you
for doing what you do
i couldn't imagine man that's that's
that's a brutal you know
it's a brutal thing to be to be dealing
with right now shout out to my brother
colin who's going to
be a first-time firefighter this this
fall
andrew lance says maybe this is the
difference between a conservative and a
libertarian
i would never place an authoritarian
despot like putin in the same category
as biden
freedom tunes on pints with aquinas 622.
who's killed more people buddy who's
killed more people
putin or biden it's a it's it's a debate
that's worth having
that's all i'm saying so if you're going
to tell me i can't compare him
i don't know john briggs says tim i
think it would be cool to have someone
who is poor
it might give some insight on what life
is currently like
yeah i can't relate dude rich as hell
well traveling
traveling the country i met a lot of
people from from all different
um economic backgrounds i stayed with
people who
some of them were very well off some of
them were very poor and this is why i
love traveling this is why i love being
on the road
this is why we were trying to get the
show on the road as well
uh is because you really get to see
america for what it really is and you
really get to meet the people
who are behind the computer and give you
such an important perspective
and i i stayed someone who wasn't doing
that well and there's so many important
lessons
and it really does humble you and makes
you appreciate what you have right now
because
it could be gone in a matter of seconds
and anyone and everyone is vulnerable
and they don't even know it yeah and let
me just say quickly i joke about being
well-off but
16 years ago my first property that i
lived in for many years was a mobile
home
so you know trailer parked at the top
baby let's do this that's where i'm at
all right
best auntie ever says what a great
monday luke is back
once again the team is complete my heart
is full don't leave us again
we'll see someone has to go to el
salvador ramble rampant 6600 says
luke just a bunch of yeah just a bunch
of use
uh i can't read japanese says it's a
japanese name i can't read it
hi luke great to see you again with tim
you guys are doing a super great work
thanks and keep it up the country need
you all
that's right
ren 3369 says luke please don't leave us
again
kyle o'brien says this show is a perfect
representation of conservative ladies
being beautiful smart and sexy while lib
ladies are terrifying just an
observation
i agree totally agreed i mean we've had
libertarian women on the show before no
no liberal ladies
oh liberal ladies yeah libertarian
ladies are quite oh yeah right right
they're great
yeah actually have we had liberal ladies
on the show oh yeah we had yeah
oh yeah she was cool though no no no no
no but she's always invited
some people just don't want to do it any
libertarian listeners out there
hit your boy up that's right we're going
to start doing some uh crossfire shows
i would love those we've got some some
prominent lefties who are excited to
come back on
and so we're really excited too because
i i i love having like hardcore leftists
and like democratic socialist types
you gotta have these conversations we
need to have these conversations we need
to bridge the gaps between people by
actually sitting down looking eye to eye
and having these real conversations that
you will never have on the
media i want to get like a couple like
very prominent leftists
and like a couple of very prominent
conservatives and libertarians we all
sit down and then say okay for today's
show all in favor of abolishing the fed
bye everyone raises their hands aye all
right everybody get up going
let's go we all agree that's it we've
unified the the fighting's over we'll
get back to fighting with ourselves
after the feds dealt with you know you
know what's funny is
how much we could come together if that
was if that was remedied because there's
so many of the issues in our in our
society today that is
that's where there's a reason the media
establishment plays on our divisiveness
of course and plays to that so much
because we have no clue who are actual
enemies exactly
j max says it's important to stay
level-headed and wait for evidence for
any claim
however doing the adverse flippantly
hand-driving away any theory conspiracy
or otherwise
can be just as bad epstein is a thing
and yet the world is cool with ignoring
it
100 agree let me just clarify my
position
when a lot of people come out and say
you know x happened
therefore we know for a fact it was z
i'm like bro bro
if people just hear z all the time you
sound
like they're not going to believe you
it's it's off the wall we need to first
go from x
then y and then people will say wait a
minute y that's right and then z and
they go oh
and then z that's right and guess what
it's not a
to c it's abc one two three
when when so i'll tell you this like
there was this thing recently where some
guy was tweeting at me saying that like
i was putting out fake news because i
had a video where i talked about
democrats being in favor of segregation
that headline alone made them think i
was making things up
because the headline was so shocking to
their perception of the world because
they only watch mainstream media
they didn't understand anything about
the policies of the democrats that have
been in favor of
like california about prop 16 abolishing
their non-discrimination laws in the
constitution which is
democrats from the federal level were
advocating removing anti-discrimination
legislation from their own constitution
that is democrats in favor
of what was supposed to be a policy to
enable racial discrimination
and then you have what's going on with
harvard and you have adamant democrat
policy proposals defending this but
because they never heard any of that
they see that headline and they're like
that's insane and so i'm like okay i
gotta
i gotta be careful about that so when
people come out and they say clinton i
go
wait you will immediately get everyone
saying
i don't wanna hear it and that's i think
jmack's point flippantly handwaving it
away is the problem
so we need to be like interesting well
let's start from the beginning and see
what we've
got in math they call it geometric
proofs just proofs in general
it's a list of showing your work step by
step of how you get to the answer and if
you go into the class and you just give
them the answer they'll fail you
right because the point of the proof is
to show each step
to show that you know how to get the
answer
similar with with reporting i think and
if there if it was a story to make
people realize the true
political power that is exemplified in
the united states it definitely is the
jeffrey epstein's story
what a crazy story dude it just came out
that the guards were like
asleep or something they made it up
they lied uh on official government
documents and they got a slap on the
wrist
for it as they were about to talk about
the corruption within that jail
and they didn't talk about the
corruption in that jail because they got
a sweetheart deal
by the feds who they were going to
criticize griffin games says hi gang my
job tried to require me to do a
diversity training gave them an
ultimatum
guess who is now unemployed because they
wouldn't do it okay i'm gonna say it one
more time
if your job comes to you and they want
you to do a diversity training here's
what i would do personally
i would say okay tell me when the moment
they bring up
any kind of critical race theory notably
because i know the lefties are like can
you define it
notably when they say like white
privilege or whiteness as property or
anything related to that
or single at any race the moment they do
that you
immediately say stop you're
discriminating against me on the basis
of my race and if you continue i'll be
following complaint with the eeoc
if they still continue pushing
race-based ideology
then you go and you file a complaint you
don't quit that's what you do
uh i don't know what you can do griffin
but maybe you can claim retaliation
because they fired you based on race
so it's quite simple they didn't fire
over diversity training they fired you
because they wanted to do racist
indoctrination and make racist comments
and you ask them not to do that and they
insisted on making racist comments
the civic nationalists so i'll just one
more time before i read this next super
chat
what does racism even mean the left has
changed the definition if you
feel a comment about race was racist and
you asked them to stop
there you go and also ian your
microphone is getting electrocuted you
might want to move that oh look at that
the power of electricity that's why
you've been so fire tonight yeah it's
legit
the civic nationalist says the queen is
the most powerful individual on the
planet
she commands six armies navies and air
forces of first world countries
americans fail to understand how other
countries work and she actually could
execute i would say it is her
office that is the most powerful office
she is very feeble and weak human no
offense lady if you're out there
you're you're healthy so the type of
people come on it's semantics
biden really runs the [ __ ] the queen
literally could
give orders and make commands yeah yeah
but she's also
could get fall down steps and die like
well yeah but come on but like whereas
you would be resilient and you'd be like
oh i hurt my leg right
but we're talking about like the
political party well i i'm
more pointing at what is power well hold
on you ready for this
christian fernandez says the queen
sliced a cake with a saber at the g7
okay meanwhile biden cannot eat a bowl
of oatmeal alone
just don't ian that woman is quite
awkward sweet queen more powerful than
biden i stand down dude
that's a real legit question who wins in
a street fight yeah i would love to see
it she's wiley
yeah not biden i don't think so no sorry
thinking about it like uh just in
disbelief i'm not going to fight her and
then she's already taken
i actually kind of really respect her
because she used to drive she drove
trucks during world war ii i think when
she was like 17 she took an active role
in
fighting the nazis for example like
she's done a heck of a lot more than
biden ever did
i would say i don't dislike her at all
personally i just i i'm reticent about
the
role of of king or queen sure in modern
day that makes sense
i disagree with you both but i'm not
getting into it all right
milk toast says tim we tried to get a
mortgage last year with a company that
rhymes with socket
they gave us the run around switching
agents asking for the same documents
over and over
then we got declined we went with a
local bank and got approved in one week
yeah that's that was going to be the
other thing i recommend is that just go
somewhere else
if your credit's as good as you said
which i believe you i don't understand
how
how they turned you down i really don't
yeah it seemed
they they the full disclosure they sent
false credit information to us
they were like here's your report and it
was completely fake like what
so ridiculously not correct in
everything it said
but it had your name on it though yeah
wow that's bizarre man yeah have you
checked
have you checked to see if you if you
got my credit is amazing
no i know but did you like verify that
recent like after you got that report
did you verify that you didn't have
some sort of hacking or yeah no no no no
yeah i checked two different reporting
two two different uh aggregators and an
official reporting agency
which shows you all your scores and i
met a lost man they were totally wrong
it seems like someone fabricated it
yeah like someone went in and just
altered the paper to make it seem like
we weren't eligible that's super
really weird never even heard of such a
thing honestly yeah i know and that's
why we were shocked when we got turned
down
because like that made no sense right
yeah
especially with you know big daddy
warbucks over here i know you balling
we're we're running a very successful
business there's like it's that you know
everybody knows we're
we're expanding we're growing and i
wanted to get a small
single family house in the area couldn't
do it
there's other ways to do it i'm not
worried about it yeah it is what it is
you see a flexibility i've never seen
tim flecks like this hippie treehugger
says biden is a puppet president and
uh slavery slavery went from black to
brown i'm hispanic and both my president
and this party don't see me as a human
being brutal
all right uh navasa says luke's analogy
about the federal reserve makes
lot uh makes lot lizards look like miss
universe
lot lizards who's that oh though okay so
those are
uh ladies who live in trailer parks and
who are very
oh unclassy looking so that would be on
par with
luke's analogy of a lady of the night
who was addicted to various
alternative substances whoa mike honcho
says a dude in atl just shot a cashier
in a cop over a mask people are snapping
crime in general here is bonkers even
the metro here feels dangerous
yikes jeez i was just there anthony
lopez says amc slash gme squeeze will be
the greatest redistribution of wealth in
history
i got some amc i just bought it because
you know i like movies
you know i wanted to dunk on elizabeth
warren real quick
uh her coming out and being the the
bastion the defender of the little guy
and yet wanting to basically destroy
bitcoin what what has made more little
guys wealthy over the past 12 months in
bitcoin
forgive me yeah you lying piece of trash
king lone wolf says tim look at reagan's
1992 rn
rnc speech two years before diagnosed
with alzheimer's then compare that with
biden speech scary
do you see that report from posobik no
trudeau was overheard saying kamala
harris will be president before the end
of 2022.
yeah whoa he's not wrong dude he's
optimistic
i know i know it's not surprising
because i'm like why should
i believe it i think the same thing yeah
i think everybody does everybody does
yeah and they're actually hanging out
with him we just see him like in this
package
tv productions do you guys know what
he's like in real life you guys see that
video of him all lost and wandering
around
then jill runs up and grabs them and
everyone busts out laughing at him
every question is pre-approved for him
with
talking points with with paper putin
literally sits down he's like asking me
anything
yeah no pre-approved questions he's just
like us
what's the british uh gordon johnson
yeah boris johnson
to uh reintroduce a guy that he'd
already introduced he's like i already
did
and then everyone laughed at the south
african president oh it hurt
wow i played that in my video today too
it would be sad
if i didn't hate joe biden but because i
hate him i don't give a [ __ ]
it's a struggle i hope he shoots his
pants on national tv i still have money
on the over under
being july 1st i feel like i'm in the
money here folks all right
drew p weiner says luke why do you never
tie
the bilderberg the fed to the larger
secret society
ah that's yeah i can't mention that no
all right marla maxson says former
missile launch officer
air bursts are used for soft targets
radars etc ground bursts take out
hardened sites icbms are designed to
destroy weapon systems
not for mass casualties interesting i
see
garhant says please discuss the american
dream film cartoon it's like freedom
tunes
and jefferson on juice against the fed
it's 30 minutes high quality
in freedom tunes format from a decade
ago it's full on
luke crack hill foam i gotta watch it
there you go mark shapcot says luke's
back i'll be watching the show again
well there you go look at that happy to
have a treat jack of all says tim i'm a
chicken whisperer after hearing your
impression
uh your impression chicken i translated
it to your chicken screaming out it's
ma'am
there you go that explains it
dana and says look up the youtube video
chicken steals mouse from cat
you'll see how vicious chickens can be
oh i'll tell you one of our chicken the
brahma
saw a mouse running alongside the coop
on the outside and then just snatched it
and
swallowed it whole a mouse this is this
is not even a full laying hen yet they
are
and she just snatched the house and just
go it was gone wow did you ever hear
terror birds
this is giant giant birds from like tens
thousands of years ago that are extinct
now and i imagine we just
we as humans wipe them out tara big
birds are terrifying
not big birds but big birds dude you
kidding me big bird's terrifying
freak out if i woke up cringe inc says
one whole bitcoin costs over 40
000 smackaroons i want to buy a bitcoin
but i don't have that kind of monies
well you're in luck you can actually buy
the small you can buy a penny's worth of
bitcoin you can buy two cents
bitcoin is divisible down to eight
decimal points you'll often find like a
ten dollar minimum purchase whenever you
buy
yeah that's doable ghost crusaders says
congrats on getting ricky gervais on the
show
okay nice that's the goatee oh
i usually get edward norton so i'll take
her get your face i put on a little
weight
there you go
israeli crusader says come on people we
need more luke simping we can't lose him
again
all right you heard it disagree super
chat how much you love luke
look at him look at him no yeah
everybody's super chat right now
big super chats i don't trust you guys
suss dragon keeper says here's a quote
from the fourth
doctor you know the very powerful and
the very stupid have one thing in common
they don't alter their views to fit the
facts they alter the facts to fit their
views
is it very stupid to be very powerful no
like george washington gave it up he saw
the wisdom and relinquishing
his potentially ultimate power very rare
i don't think it's stupid i think it's
noble
but rare yeah lil willy says there's a
sticker on the back of luke's mic
that is correct in fact there's a
sticker on every mic it
shows the color that we use to
coordinate
sounds yellow yeah that's the that's the
secret
the wildest of all says crt or any other
program with a similar ideology can only
work with educated american idiots who
are unaware of the history of every
other country
that's right one of the core components
of critical race theory is the idea that
whiteness
is property which makes no sense because
luke is not white
nope according to the coalition of
communities of color
luke is a blonde hair blue-eyed white
man but he's actually a person of color
because he's slavic
these people are insane critical race
theory makes no sense
and it is a false it is a fake academic
theory of really dumb people
whose actual goal is to rewind civil
rights and bring back an identitarian
society
let me explain identitarianism has been
the law of the world for
human history it's only 56 years
where we've actually had laws
restricting identitarianism which is
government based on your identity most
countries almost all of them are still
identitarian
europe is very humanitarian and now in
the united states we've got civil rights
and a bunch of critical race theorists
lying to dumb liberals
to reinstate identitarian rule of law
i'm not all about that i think that's a
bad thing
anti that's right nathan young says
clint is the man so glad you got him on
the show check out the chinese buying
land in rural oklahoma
and offering five times the asking price
why don't we ban that that seems like
it's a really bad thing
you know we shouldn't allow that stuff
why is that allowed
all right evan freshwater says
clint on tim cass should be a regular
thing though one of you needs a
different facial hair to tell the
difference
that's wrong jason benoist says
i cannot wait for tonight's members
bonus segment welcome back luke keep
doing what you do
tim poole your team makes the world a
better place thank you all so much
and thank you luke for for finally
coming back
we were crying every night i know before
the show we would all cry
for like an hour yeah hold hands in a
circle and then it was so sad
i didn't expect anything else yeah luke
walked and everybody was crying and we
lifted him up and we were bouncing him
and like
[Music]
all right um says i recommend an anime
psycho pass
oh you know what show i like psychomob
100 is that what it's called i don't
know i've never heard of it i need to
watch more of that i stopped watching at
a certain point because i just been so
busy
do you ever see psycho cop cycle cop 2
psycho cop returns
all right let's see what do we got
jumbled pro says great to see you back
luke sad to see you left florida but
hopefully you can convince tim and
friends to come live in our piece of
muggy heaven no
that's what i've been trying to do that
was my that was my strategy because we
were talking about
taking the show on the road i was like
you know maybe if i leave maybe i'll
incentivize it because it would be
so amazing to have this show in front of
a live audience
and to have a t-shirt go we are and
here's the thing
we got to get starling okay because so
here's my understanding is that starlink
is satellite locked it's cell locked so
we had one dude came out brought us a
star link doesn't work out here because
it only works in certain regions
so we have to wait till we get it but
when you do you get like i think a 300
mile radius
once starlink goes like nationwide you
can mount starlink on an rv
and go anywhere and it's like 100
megabits up so you can do the show low
latency that would be incredible
then we got the rv we're we're half
there we need to we need to do
uh studio setup for the rv it's a fifth
wheel and then we can literally
tow a podcast studio and the plan is
nashville austin nashville back
so we'd spend a week in each place and
then come back because that's like you
know you got a bunch of people in
asheville you got a bunch of people in
austin
so those are the places we had maybe
maybe nashville austin then somewhere
else and then come back maybe atlanta or
something that was actually my plan for
this summer i was gonna get
i was gonna do the liberty lockdown tour
because it's you know ironic or whatever
uh but then i decided but someone talked
me out of it they said that doing it by
myself would be lonely but apparently
you're loving life i love it i
absolutely love it i got my dog i got my
rv i got my truck
and uh i got things dangling off of my
truck that we can't talk about here
but i i love i love the i love that
lifestyle all right let's do one more we
got
r bracewell says luke is back stay where
you are you are better served in the
belief compound a great pushback to tim
love you and the show you see you gotta
gotta stick around it's
it's difficult because you know we're
still figuring things out there's a
vagabond there's there's pork fest
you know you know i really there's el
salvador el salvador's doing incredible
things i'm working on trying and getting
an interview with the president there
and like you get permanent residency
there if you have some if you have three
bitcoins
you spend it though isn't it oh yeah you
have to invest it yet the imf and the
and the
and the u.s state department are really
angry so this could go either way i'm
paying very close attention to that
situation but uh i i really want to
let's do the show in el salvador i would
let's let's
we'll need to get like an armed convoy
if we're going to drive down there
tucker carlson did a live report from
there talking about how crime is going
down
dramatically because of some of the
policies instituted by the new younger
president that are more realistic
than the previous president but again
it's all a part of the war on drugs
which is a big war on the american
people
that just screws and hurts people all
the time so there's a lot of exciting
things happening in latin america a lot
of things happening outside the world
and we kind of have to experience it by
going there so it's it's difficult
i love being here i love the audience
you you really have cultivated
some of the most intelligent people on
the internet to come together
to be a part of this larger community
and i'm just humbled to be able to
people people get intimidated by the
audience because they're smarter than
guests yeah you can't you can't lie to
them you can't bullcrap them if
somebody's
crack yeah i'm not right all the time i
can't even pronounce sentences correctly
sometimes
you know and and then i i love the the
const of
the constant criticism i love the
feedback i love trying to be the best i
can and i can only do that if
i listen to other people and that's the
best way to do it
well said well my friends what you got
to do you got to go to timcast.com
become a member there's going to be a
bonus segment coming up at about 11 p.m
is when it goes live
and we're gonna uh say a bunch of things
youtube doesn't like us to say just have
a good time of it luke's finally back so
we'll just you know
have a good time and uh tomorrow we are
officially bringing in
our new editor-in-chief who's going to
start working on articles and it's
slow roll we got a couple other people
that will probably be joining very soon
i'm hoping that within about two weeks
we'll have about five people in the
newsroom
dedicated fact checker who will actually
fact check us
and others and write articles doing
analysis we got we got plans
but this requires technological
development we're not just gonna have a
regular news site where it's like an
article
to start we are but the ultimate goal is
to have like a very dynamic system where
we'll actually when we go through a
story show like here the sources we went
through
these four were seem to be mostly
correct this one was lying and then we
can actually show you
in our research what we find so we have
a lot of plans should be starting with
articles tomorrow it'll be fairly simple
we're gonna get the ball rolling because
like i always say if you want to start
something you just start doing it
stick around for that it's all dependent
upon whether or not the website
currently can handle the format for
written articles i'm not entirely sure
but we'll do our best
with that being said you can follow us
on facebook at tim cast irl and
instagram
cast irl you can follow me personally at
tim cast and when you follow us on
facebook you can share these videos we
want to leverage the platform
get people to go to the website so we
can expand this newsroom expand this
company produce new shows new podcasts
we got a paranormal podcast
we're gonna be doing mini documentaries
maybe we'll just send luke with a crew
down to el salvador to do a documentary
and do these interviews
that's the plan and it's because you
guys are members we're able to do it so
again you can follow me
at tim cast the show is live monday
friday at 8 pm uh
uh do you want to shout anything out
clint your show uh yeah at
libertylockpod on twitter
libertylockdown on instagram spotify
itunes youtube everywhere else
i just want to say thank you to tim for
having me on it's a dream
and uh thanks for coming pleasure to
meet everybody right on it's a lot of
fun and if you want to support me
you can by simply purchasing a t-shirt
like the one i'm wearing right now
that says make florida america and you
can get that um it says make america
florida make america florida
you know flirty and slit whatever on the
bernadian slip
the the best political shirts.com is the
website and if you want to get involved
what i'm doing i'm doing a lot of
exciting fun things on luke uncensored
dot com
luke uncensored dot com thanks so much
for having me on that sounds awesome
yeah uh okay i mean crosslanding
fallmedia and crossland.net and
ian crossland on all social media i'm
just glad to be here glad to see you
guys again
clint you're the man udemy you rock i am
so glad that luke is back we have
absolutely missed him and there's been
way too much space in the parking lot so
i'm delighted to have him back with us
again
you guys can follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids as i attempt to have more
followers and sour patch kids so i
really need all your help
make sure you go to timcast.com but also
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe
we'll see you all live tomorrow and
we'll see you around 11 p.m with the
bonus segment
with luke back in the house at
timcast.com
you